Hier ist Chaosradio 190.
Und der ist jetzt in der Mitte.
Und der ist jetzt in der Mitte. Und der ist in der Mitte.
Und der ist in der Mitte.
Und der ist in der Mitte. Und der ist in der Mitte. Und der ist in der Mitte. Und der ist in der Mitte.
Und der ist in der Mitte. Und der ist in der Mitte. Und der ist in der Mitte.
Und der ist in der Mitte. Und der ist in der Mitte. Und der ist in der Mitte. Da steht irgendwo Wort und Musik.
Ja, oh besser.
Das sind die Nachrichtensprecher, die sind da komplett schmerzfrei. Ich weiß nicht, wie die das machen. Die schaffen das, ihre Nachrichten vorzulesen und sich selbst mit irgendwie so einer Verzögerung von, wie viel war das jetzt? Zehntel Sekunde?
Schon verstörend genug, als dass ich keine Lust mehr hatte, was zu sagen.
Sehr schön. So, worum geht's denn eigentlich heute?
Heute geht's ums 3D-Drucken. So was man bei sich zu Hause hinstellen kann, wenn so Captain Picard hingeht und sagt so, gray, warum will er den?
Hot. Gray hot.
Genau.
Oder die Sache, bei der CDU-Mitglieder nachts schreiend aufwachen, weil jetzt alle Waffen drucken können.
Oh, nicht das Wort.
Welches?
Dieses W-Wort.
Waffeln.
Wollen wir denn die anderen beiden Gäste noch mit begrüßen?
Hab ich doch grad. Reicht das nicht? Mann ey, das ist schon komisch, früher wart ihr alle irgendwie lockerer.
Guten Abend.
Wie qualifiziert dich denn eigentlich, in dieser Sendung teilzunehmen, Micha?
Ich hab Abitur.
Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
Demütigt uns alle.
Nee, ich bin seit Anfang 2012 so ein bisschen im Hacker-Space, in der Raumfahrtagentur aktiv, mach da mit 3D-Drucken so ein bisschen rum und schreib jetzt auch meine Masterarbeit zum Thema 3D-Drucken.
Wie heißt denn die Masterarbeit, oder ist das der ganze Titel?
Das steht noch nicht ganz fest, es geht wahrscheinlich FDM Printing Process Optimization oder Out of the Box Printing oder irgendwie sowas.
Das Problem ist, ich bin halt Geisteswissenschaftler. Und ich dachte, das wäre jetzt irgendwie einer von diesen Larifare Geisteswissenschaftler-Titeln in der Masterarbeit, die jeder versteht und wo hinten nichts bei rumkommt.
Das hast du bloß nicht gemerkt, weil wir Englisch schon mit vielen Bass hören.
Das heißt, ich bin nicht nur Geisteswissenschaftler, ich bin auch sonst doof.
Deine Worte, nicht meine.
Hallo, Pat. Was willst du hier?
Was ich hier will? Ja, ich bin zufällig hier. Nee, ich hab einen 3D-Drucker seit zwei Jahren.
Du musst vor allem ins Mikrofon sprechen. Ich hab dran vorbei.
Ah, okay. Ich kenne gleich geiler, oder? Ja, auch bei mir jetzt. Auf jeden Fall, ich hab einen 3D-Drucker seit zwei Jahren insbesondere und deswegen weiß ich ein bisschen was über 3D-Drucker und hab schon so einiges durchgemacht.
Das haben auch nicht so viele Leute so ein Ding, oder? Wie viele stehen da so rum? Weiß man das?
Ich hab einige gesehen, bevor ich mir selbst eingeholt hab, irgendwie. Und auf jeden Fall, weiß ich nicht, also so vereinzelt Leute, die basteln können, die haben sowas schon. Kann man schon haben.
Bestimmt zu tausend in der Welt gibt's da. Und vor allem in China gibt's bestimmt noch viel mehr. Die basteln ja echt gerne, wenn man so mal die Plasteteile von da ankickt.
Also die werden zu Hause verkauft.
Was kostet so ein Ding mittlerweile? Das letzte Mal hab ich gesehen, das waren 1000 Dollar, glaube ich, für so ein...
Na je nachdem, wie viel Aufwand man selber reinstecken will. Man kann mit 500 Euro anfangen, wenn man viel basteln will. Und so 1000 Euro, wenn man ein bisschen weniger basteln will. 2000 Euro, wenn man gar nicht basteln will. Und dann gibt's drauf bis 10.000 Euro für professionelle Geräte. Was heißt professionelles Gerät?
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen professionellen und amateurgeräten?
3D-Drucker gibt's schon lange im Prototyping-Bereich. Wenn man Modelle machen muss für das, was man groß machen will, ein Auto zum Beispiel, dann kann man das drucken schon eine ganze Ewigkeit. Da gibt's professionelle Geräte, die das sehr fein machen. Auch in allen möglichen Materialien. Was man im Hobbybereich macht, ist ein bisschen was anderes.
Ich muss dazu sagen, es gibt auch verschiedene Verfahren, wie man 3D drucken kann sozusagen. Wir machen jetzt, also Petsdrucker oder eine Raumfahrtagentur, da machen wir halt hauptsächlich nur FDM Printing. Das ist halt Plastikdrucken letztendlich. Diese speziellen hoch... Also es gibt halt, man kann ja auch mit, keine Ahnung, mit Keramik drucken.
Ach, ich wollte gerade sagen, womit denn sonst denn? Nicht mit Plastik, nicht mit Keramik?
Metall, aber, ja, geht auch. Aber so ein Ding kostet halt eine Million oder so.
Scheißegal, wo kann ich das haben?
Wo kann ich das herkriegen?
Krasse Banasafragen oder so, die haben so ein Ding.
Weil du kriegst da so eine Handvoll Metallpulver und dann würfst du das da oben so rein und dann machen die da echt heiß und danach hast du dann eine fertige Metallform.
Das ist das Bleigießen in echt. Also in ordentlich.
Und das hält dann auch.
Kann man in Düsenjets einbauen?
Und Keramik, wie macht man das mit Keramik?
Das geht auch so. Also es gibt halt dieses 3D-Drucken, wo man halt Material Schicht für Schicht aufträgt. Und dann gibt es halt dieses Sintan, wo halt so da ist halt so Pulver in so einer Schale drin. Und die wird dann, der Laser fährt dann so Schicht für Schicht, wird immer so eine Schicht Pulver aufgetragen. Der Laser fährt drüber, macht dieses Pulver hart. Und dann wird die nächste Schicht aufgetragen. Und irgendwann hat man dann so ein fertiges Objekt. Ja, und das geht halt wohl mit Keramik halt auch. Ich weiß, die Stoffe weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, was da jetzt verwendet wird, aber es geht wohl.
Also Hauptsache ist es heiß genug dann, ne?
Genau, das Bett muss auch vorgeheizt werden. Also möglichst nahe des Schmelzpunkts, dass du da nicht so viel Energie für den Laser noch brauchst.
Was druckt man denn damit da?
Soll ich eigentlich die Unterlegmusik wieder anmachen, wo sich alle immer so beschweren?
Ich bin jetzt mit Absicht nicht im IRC, um mal zu fragen.
Wenn die nichts sagen, und du siehst ja, die sagen nichts.
Bei mir hat sich keiner beschwert.
Bei mir bisher auch nicht, kann ich ja eigentlich doch noch mal. Wo waren wir stehen geblieben?
Ich wollte eigentlich gerade wissen, was sich die Jungs da so alle selber drucken.
Ja, man kann alles Mögliche drucken, Ersatzteile. Und wenn man irgendwas kaputt ist, also ein paar Beispiele. Ich hab mal angefangen, auf dem Kent war das irgendwie 2011. Da ist mir die Idee gekommen, was ich drucken könnte. Ich hab eine Tochter, die wollte unsere elektrische Zahnbürste benutzen. Da haben wir so einen Halter für die Zahnbürstenköpfe. Der hat fast zwei Zahnbürstenköpfe. Und unsere Tochter wollte auch mal elektrische Zahnbürste benutzen. Und dann hab ich mir überlegt, dann könnte man ja mal einen Dreier daraus machen. Also diesen Stand, also diese Ständer dafür, nehmen und verändern und wieder ausdrucken. Und das ist ein ganz gutes Beispiel gewesen, wo ich eingestiegen bin. Ansonsten kann man alles Mögliche drucken. Also Sachen, die halten müssen, Sachen, Ersatzteile, kleine Teile, die fehlen. Gehäuse, whatever.
Na, in der Raumfahrtagentur sind ja die Fahrradbastler da unterwegs, die ihr E-Bikes machen und da zum Prototypen von mal irgendwelchen Haltern, irgendwelchen Lastaufnahmen, so.
So was ist das cool, stimmt.
Überall, wo du so kleine Plastennups hast, wo du dich ärgerst, dass das jetzt aus China, nicht aus dem Container, in 100.000-fach schon fertig und billig kommt und deswegen es keiner mehr herstellt, weil es sich nicht lohnt. Und du nicht wirklich mit der Holzsäge mehr zusägen möchtest.
Das wär doch eigentlich auch ein prima Geschäftsmodell, oder? Irgendein Laden, wo du hingehst und sagst, wir drucken ihnen die Ersatzteile. Aber dazu muss man auch Euch kennen.
Blöd, das machen die Jungs sogar als Business, aber ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir... Das geht ja schon mehr an die Schleichwerbung hieran, das wollt ich gar nicht.
Oh nee, böse, ganz schöne Sache. Schleichwerbung, kauft lieber Reis. Geht nicht in die Raumfahrtagentur, um Euch da Sachen ausdrucken zu lassen. Kauft Reis.
Aber eigentlich... Von der Idee her ist es doch total cool, dass diesen ganzen China-Kram, wo man eh nicht damit rechnen kann, dass wenn man sich heute sowas kauft und in 10 Jahren geht ein Stück kaputt, gibst du wie Flower Power Enterpreises. Zwei Jahren. Ja, ich war jetzt mal großzügig. Also jetzt mal gegen Miele oder so, wenn du dir so richtige seröse Haushaltselektronik holst, dann ist ja ein Bauteil kaputt, geh zum Händler und sag mir, ich brauch Ersatzteil, der lacht dich aus. Sag billiger, kauf dir lieber eine neue Maschine. Du kannst dir jetzt einfach so gucken, was fehlt und die einfach selber ausdrucken. Das ist eigentlich schon ziemlich geil.
Ich hab mir eine Kühltasche repariert irgendwie. Und zwar ist da oben an dem Henkel ja so ein Verschluss dran, damit man die dann hochheben kann und damit das nicht aufgeht, das Teil. Und da war halt so eine kleine Nut abgebrochen und die konnte ich dann halt nachdrucken. Kurz reingebohrt, ein Loch gebohrt. Also an die Stelle, wo eigentlich diese Nut war. Und hab das dann da reingesteckt und festgeklebt. Und dann konnte ich halt die Kühltasche wieder benutzen. Ich meine, sonst hätte ich das ganze Plastik weggeschmissen und mir neue gekauft.
Kennt ihr irgendwen, der so einen Metalldrucker hat? Also habt ihr damit schon mal rumgespielt? Haben.
Wer so viel Spielgeld über hat, den würde ich jetzt echt noch gerne als Freund haben. Aber gibt es bestimmt dann irgendwelche Universitäten oder so?
Also ich weiß halt nur, an der TU, da gibt es dieses 3D-Labor vom Mathematikfachbereich und die haben aber auch bloß, also bloß ist gut, auch so einen professionellen FDM-Plastikdrucker. Der ist dann so groß wie ein Kühlschrank und diese professionellen Drucker, die sind dann auch schon richtig justiert und wenn man die halt einschaltet, dann kann man davon ausgehen, dass die auch funktionieren und das ist bei diesen 1000-Euro-Druckern nicht unbedingt der Fall. Also da muss man dann immer ziemlich viel per Hand noch nachjustieren.
Ja, das hätte ich nämlich jetzt mich auch gefragt. Wie nehmt ihr denn da Maß? Also gehst du wirklich so mit dem, wie heißt das Ding? Schieblehre dran?
Schieblehre auf jeden Fall gehört dazu. Ganz viel. Nee, also ich weiß nicht, also mein Drucker, den ich geholt habe, der kommt in Einzelteile, ein ganz Komplettset, dann hab ich zwei Tage dran gebastelt, also nachdem ich acht Wochen gewartet hab.
Findet ihr die Musik auch so wahnsinnig nervtötend?
Ich kann so was ausblenden.
Ich nicht, das ist furchtbar.
Warum hast du den angemacht?
Trollen halt, den hat's erwischt. Ich mach das jetzt wieder aus, das ist ja furchtbar.
Vielleicht musst du Blasmusik drunter tun.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, das wär Blasmusik. So, Entschuldigung. Ja, zwei Tage hast du gebraucht, um das aufzubauen.
Genau, war ein Riesenspaß, weil die haben sich das gut überlegt. Das Teil ist zum größten Teil das Holz, das ganze Gehäuse. Dann kommen da ein paar Stangen rein, ein paar Motoren, ein paar Axialager. Es ist schon eine ganz schöne Bastelei, hat echt Spaß gemacht. Dann wirst du das Ding an und dann weißt du keine Parameter. Da ist irgendeine Software drin, ich hab da Open Source Software reingemacht, die zusammengestrickt ist, für verschiedene Drucker funktioniert. Dann druckt man halt was und dann kommt auch was raus. Ich war auch total positiv überrascht erstmal, aber letztendlich war es Moks, es war viel zu dünn, die Temperatur war falsch und so. Dann fängt man halt an, ein bisschen rumzuspielen, bis man so ein bisschen raus hat, wie man drucken kann. Und dann gibt es eine Menge Probleme, die man noch zu lösen hat. Du fängst an, so einen Kasten zu drucken, um zu gucken, ob die Maß überhaupt stimmt. Du hast Schalter, die verhindern, dass das Ding gegenrennt, gegen die Seite, so Endstops, dass das nicht über das mögliche Maß hinausfährt. Und dann die Riemen durchrattern, die man richtig einstellen muss. Dann druckst du auf so einem Bett, also so einer Platte. Die muss auch richtig eingestellt werden, sodass du auch gerade darauf druckst. Das muss man alles von anhand machen.
Das klingt nicht so, als gäbe es auch so ein schönes, nettes Gui, auf dem ich mir dann so Sachen zusammenklicke. Also so ein Millimeter Papier, auf dem ich dann so schon mal Skizze machen kann, und die wird dann gedruckt.
Ja, also du kannst natürlich Software kaufen, die super funktioniert.
Wenn du ins Mikrofon schmutz, versteht man nicht total gut.
Ach, hier ist ein Mikro.
Das ist ein Mikro, das lange schwarze Ding.
Aber den sehe ich nicht mehr.
Ja, man muss halt lernen, so mit den Augen zu gucken. Du musst mit den Augen gucken.
Wo war ich jetzt stehen geblieben?
Aber du wolltest halt immer weiter vom Mikrofon.
Bei der Software warst du.
Bei der Software, genau. Also, es gibt halt, das eine Ding ist halt irgendwie, sich so ein 3D-Modell zu überlegen. Und da gibt es halt so CAT-Software irgendwie und irgendwelche andere 3D-Software, mit der man irgendwelche Modelle bauen kann. Ist halt alles ziemlich kryptisch irgendwie. Muss man sich mit auskennen. Da gibt es noch diverse andere Lösungen für Programmierer, wo man das tippen kann. Zum Beispiel, sowas benutze ich. Das ist so ein OpenSCAD. Das ist ein Open Source Projekt, wo man halt irgendwie so eine Art Programmcode schreibt. Und dann kommt da ein 3D-Modell raus.
Ist das dann am Ende der Pfad, den der Kopf beschreibt beim Drucken?
Nein, noch nicht mal. Also, erstmal hast du so ein 3D-Modell irgendwie. Das ist ja schon mal so das Pendant zu einem Foto, was du drucken willst oder sowas, ja. Und dann muss es aber noch aufs Papier, also beim Drucker aufs Papier kommen und beim 3D-Drucker muss es dann halt aus der Düse rauskommen. Und da gibt es halt noch eine Software dazwischen, die recht komplex ist, weil die viele geometrische Probleme lösen muss. Nennt sich Slicer. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es sich so nennt, aber die meisten heißen so. Und der zerschneidet halt im Prinzip das 3D-Modell an lauter Schichten. Und da hält da draus so Polygone, die jede einzelne Schicht beschreiben, wie bei so einer Tomographie, wie man sich das so vorstellt vielleicht. Und diese einzelnen Schichten werden dann wieder analysiert und dann wird so ein Fahrweg für jede Schicht festgelegt, auf dem die Düse dann langläuft und so einen Plastikstrang ausspuckt, der sich dann aufstapelt und so weiter und so fort. Und das ist natürlich eine Menge eine Haube auch mal dafür, um sowas richtig zu machen.
Wie verhindert das Ding eigentlich? Der 3D-Drucker, der legt ja eine Wurst und auf die Wurst noch eine Wurst. Wie verhindert das, dass die eine Wurst von der anderen Wurst runterrollt?
Das geht nicht. Das muss diese Slicer-Software vorher ausrechnen. Ob die jetzt da noch Stützmaterial braucht oder nicht. Da gibt es keine Sensorik für oder so. Das muss halt die Software vorher machen.
Es gibt Stützmaterial. Das heißt, du druckst praktisch Du kannst dich in der Luft drucken.
Du kannst ja nicht irgendwo in die Luft drucken. Du musst halt irgendwie was drunter haben. Du musst es stapeln.
Ich dachte, du fängst mit der untersten Schicht an.
Ja, wenn du eine Pyramide druckst, ist das ganz einfach. Dann fängst du halt mit einem großen Quadrat an und immer ein kleineres Quadrat und so weiter und so fort. Aber wenn die Pyramide auf der Spitze stehen soll, dann musst du halt zusehen, dass die Winkel nicht so flach sind, dass du das nicht mehr aufeinander stapeln kannst, sondern du schaust halt zu, dass du, wenn das so ist, irgendwie Stützmaterial einbringst. Also zusätzlich Material in das 3D-Modell reinbringst, was man herweg macht.
Die, die du im Überraschungsei damals immer gehabt hast zwischen den Plasteteilen, das sind Stützschnubs.
Aber die druckst du mit? Die werden direkt mitgedruckt und du gehst nicht in die Masse? Aus Streichhölzern, so kleine Türntchen.
Und da gibt es auch noch so einen Unterschied zwischen den professionellen und diesen 1000-Euro-Druckern. Also wenn ich bei Stratasys so einen Drucker kaufe, der hat meistens auch zwei Extruder, also der kann zwei Würste gleichzeitig drucken. Und eine Wurst drückt dann so dieses Stützmaterial, was meistens wasserlöslich ist. Und das kann ich dann am Ende auswaschen, und dann kann ich es einfach ablösen und hab dann das fertige Objekt bei den 1000 Euro Druckern, die nur einen Extruder haben, da muss ich das dann abbrechen oder abfeilen oder wie auch immer. Extruder ist die Düse, wo die Wurst rauskommt. Da wird die Wurst heiß gemacht und rausgedrückt.
Das war nicht sehr das Hotend, aber okay.
Damit man sich vorstellen kann, wie so ein Ding überhaupt funktioniert, sollten wir vielleicht mal erzählen, wie so ein 3D-Drucker, wenn man so draufguckt von der Seite, wie der überhaupt funktioniert.
Wie so auf dem Rummelplatz so ein Greifding, womit man so Plüschtiere grundsätzlich nicht erwischt.
Ja, ganz andersrum, ja.
Andersrum? Also da sind jetzt keine Plüschtiere drin.
Nee, er nimmt kein Material weg, er tut ja welches zu.
Ja klar, aber da ist ja anstatt einem Greif eine Düse dran, wo die Wurst warm gemacht wird und rausgepresst wird. Habt ihr eigentlich da auch, wenn ihr sowas sagt, immer direkt so ein Defekier-Bild im Kopf? Nee, so eine Düse, wo die Wurst rausgepresst wird. Ich hab immer so, ich frag mich gerade die ganze Zeit, ob das jetzt irgendwie mein Gehirn nur ist, das kaputt ist oder?
Also wir haben mal so Videoaufnahmen gemacht, so ein bisschen Timelapse-Videos. Und mit Makro-Aufnahmen, da kann man halt ziemlich genau sehen, wie diese Wurst da hingelegt wird. Und das sieht er, also da, da. Wir hatten also blaues Filament, also blaues Plastik irgendwie. Und jetzt kommt das Mikro. Willst du mein Mikro neu justieren?
Was der Hörer gerade nicht sehen konnte, ist, dass Holgi sich echt mal um den ganzen großen Tisch rumbewegt hat, um das Mikro eigenhändig auszurichten.
Genau, und zwar relativ langsam, sodass es aussah, als würde ich dir jetzt eins auf die Fresse hauen wollen, kann das sein?
Ja, ich dachte schon, ich lasse mich auf die Fresse.
Nein, ich dachte mir nur, ich gehe langsam, damit du deinen Satz zu Ende sprechen kannst, bevor ich das Mikrofon anpacke. Aber gut.
Ja, bei diesen Aufnahmen da sieht es mehr aus, wie Zahnpasta irgendwie, die mal dir so hingelegt wird, so ein bisschen irgendwie so. Also das ist halt so ein Strang irgendwie aus Plastik und das ist so wie Heißkleber, kann man sich das ein bisschen vorstellen. Also auf so Ideen komm ich eigentlich nicht.
Na gut, wo waren wir stehen?
Du hast Zivi gemacht, sagst du?
Ja, wir wollten das mal erklären.
Hast du mal alte Leute genommen und gedrückt?
Wieso, die muss man nicht drücken, da läuft das von alleine raus.
Und dann musst du einfach nur über der Bettdecke ein Muster bewegen.
Irgendwann fängt der Hahn an zu tropfen, auch deine. Hätten wir jetzt Unterlegmusik, könnte ich die jetzt schön aufziehen und ein bisschen dudeln lassen, aber nein, die Hörerschaft will das ja nicht.
Wir könnten auch dudeln. Oder so ein 3D-Drucker, da hört sich eigentlich, hatten wir mal so ein 3D-Drucker aufnehmen sollen, während er da so lang fährt. Vor allem, wenn er dann so diese Spuren macht. Ich glaube, wenn man erfahren genug ist, dann kann man einfach nur, man hört dann einfach schon auch jetzt druckt, mich ja wieder, weil die Pyramide wird immer schneller, kleiner.
Ja, tatsächlich. Also gerade bei so einem mathematischen Modell, die jetzt total komplex sind und so ganz regelmäßige Strukturen haben, dann hört das nächste und dann wird er langsamer, wenn er wie eine lange Strecke drucken muss und so. Hat auch natürlich, haben dann auch gleich wieder Leute auf YouTube, die dann den Imperial March von Star Wars mit dem 3D-Drucker nachstellen mussten. Da war natürlich wieder klar, dass das getan werden soll.
Boah, haben die Leute immer diese Zeit eher?
Ja, das frag ich mich auch. Da hat man schon gedrückt und es genervt, dass alles kaputt ist, was man druckt. Und dann kommt man auf solche Ideen.
Wie lange habt ihr gebraucht, um überhaupt nur das erste benutzbare Stück zu drucken?
Naja, ich würde sagen, ich hab es zwei Wochen lang erst mal so rumprobiert, bis ich, also ich hatte zwischendurch ein paar Erfolgserlebnisse, aber bis ich es unter Kontrolle hatte, so einigermaßen, wo ich mir gesagt habe, jetzt kann ich auch das drucken, was ich wollte, aber ich leg's halt auch echt darauf an, dass ich ja bestimmte Sachen druck, also ich hab, ich wollte zum Beispiel Schmuck drucken, das ist halt ziemlich klein und fein und da musst du halt ein bisschen rumprobieren. Ein bisschen, ich hab mit den Temperaturen viel gespielt und so und mir auch sehr viel Freiheiten genommen, also sicher. Wenn man sich jetzt eine Lösung nimmt, irgendwie eine fertige Software kauft für, weiß ich, 150 Euro oder sowas, dann sind da, da sind da schon Settings drin, die funktionieren und dann kann man auch schon ziemlich schnell losdrucken. Also so geht das halt auch.
Ich versuch mir grad vorzustellen, da gab's doch die, irgendjemand der mit so einem Xbox-Sensor, wie hieß dieses?
Kinect?
Mit der Kinect irgendwie so seine Visage abgefahren und dann gleich da das 3D-Modell da draus fallen lassen. Hätten wir die eigentlich auch eine Büste machen können?
Uh, stimmt.
Was einem jetzt immer alles einfällt, wenn man irgendwie...
Hast du ein 3D-Modell von dir?
Ne, grad nicht.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Weil, weiß ich nicht.
Nimm einfach ein Buddha, das geht.
Das würde funktionieren. Also es reicht mit so einem, mit so einem, was ist denn das? Das ist so ein... Was ist da drin?
Ein Infrarot-Laser-Kamera-Projektor?
Ne, die haben einen Projektor, wo sie so einen Punktmuster in den Raum schießen und dann von der anderen Seite drauf gucken und dann da einfach ausrechnen, dadurch wie sich das Muster der Punkte verschiebt gegen das, was sie annehmen, wo sie sein müssten. Wenn man aus der Blickrichtung guckt, dann gehen sie davon aus, dass wenn sie sich so und so verschoben haben, da so ein näherer oder kleiner...
Das reicht, um so ein Porträt zu drucken? Das reicht.
Man muss noch ein bisschen nachbearbeiten. Es kommt erst mal so eine Punktwolke raus, wo diese ganzen Abtastpunkte gespeichert sind. Die muss man dann noch in dieses 3D-Modell umwandeln. Das ist noch nicht das fertige 3D-Modell, sondern das sind erst mal nur Punkte. Das 3D-Modell ist ja dieses Eingabeformat, das diese Software liest. Es heißt STL. Das ist im Prinzip so eine Triangle-Zube dazu. Eine Liste von Dreiecken, die diese Oberfläche beschreiben. Das muss man erst mal umrechnen von dieser Punktwolke auf dieses STL. Dann treten wahrscheinlich noch ein Haufen Probleme auf. Dann kann man sich selber ausdrucken, wenn man Lust hat.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie malen nach Zahlen ohne Zahlen. Man hat einen Haufen Punkte und muss sie richtig miteinander verbinden, dass man da so ein 3D-Modell rauskriegt. Das ist beim Scannen das Problem. Manchmal ist es schwierig, wenn du eine ganz dünne, schmale Lücke hast. Ob da jetzt die Punkte verbunden sind, die du gemessen hast, weißt du ja nicht. Oder ob das eine Lücke sein soll. Deshalb muss man möglichst genau scannen, möglichst viele Abtastpunkte haben, damit man eben darüber Annahmen stellen kann, welche Punkte zu welchen gehören, wo die Flächen sind und wo da Material ist.
Wird das irgendwann eine Revolution sein oder eine Revolution auslösen? Oder bleibt das Spielerei?
Das ist doch endlich hier Marks Idee von Produktionsmittel in Bürgerhand. Jeder kann, muss man nicht große Fabrikdirektor sein.
Ich kann mir dann mit einem 1000 Euro Maker-Bot einen Kochlöffel machen, der mir in der Pfanne wegschmilzt.
Warum noch Löffel? Oder eine Pfanne?
Du brauchst eigentlich gar keinen Kochlöffel. Du brauchst gar nicht mehr kochen, weil das Essen kommt ja auch aus dem Drucker.
Und schmeckt immer wie Hühnchen.
Genau.
Die drucken unser Essen immer.
Auf der anderen Seite ist ja, seinen selbst gedruckten Löffel, Teller, irgendwas zu haben, da hat man, für Kinder muss es total geil sein, nicht mehr nach Hause zu kommen mit irgendwie was Getöpferten. Was ist es? Aschenbecher? Oder was war das andere, was man immer so macht?
Handschmeichler aus Speckstein.
So, so. Hier Mama hat was Nützliches gemacht.
Ein Löffel.
Viel cooler geht doch gar nicht.
Das verstehen Eltern nicht. Guck mal, ich hab einen Löffel gedruckt. Ja, Kind.
Hauptsache du machst was Nützliches.
Wir wollten doch eh mal zum Arzt. Aber ernsthaft, ist das in der Lage, eine Revolution auszulösen, oder bleibt das Spielerei, weil es doch begrenzt ist? Es wird nicht jeder einen Metalldrucker zu Hause haben können, oder?
Die Frage ist, was man erwartet von der Revolution. Also wenn man jetzt irgendwie so sagt, ich will jetzt alles drucken können, dann ist das erstmal recht schwierig. Da sind noch ein paar Probleme zu lösen. Also zum Beispiel kann ich kein elektronisches Gerät drucken oder sowas. Ich kann nichts Komplexes drucken. Also so Gegenstände, die wir hier so rumstehen haben, Monitor, Mikrofon kann ich nicht drucken. Aber ich kann halt so Teile drucken, also Gehäuse-Teile oder irgendwas, was halt einfach nur aus Material besteht. Man kann halt davon eine Menge erwarten, aber erstmal sieht es so aus, dass du einfach Einzelteile druckst.
Ich denke, so viele Pappis wie der Laubsäge arbeiten in ihrem Keller, um dann da Formen draus zu haben, weil man im Haushalt ja immer mal braucht, dann Haken oder da ist da mal was kaputt gegangen. Das ist doch total toll, wenn es nur 200 Euro kostet, hat man es halt im Keller stehen. Und dann macht man sich halt ein Gitmen.
Auf dem Camp hatten wir das mit den Duschen, da haben die Haken gefehlt für die Wäsche. Und da hat sich irgendjemand so ein Modell ausgedacht, wo man das einfach so über die Duschtür hängt da. Und dann hat man halt einen Haken. Und das haben die da live gedruckt. Und dann am zweiten oder dritten Tag waren da Haken verfügbar. Das ist schon ganz cool eigentlich.
Wir machen Nachrichten, danach geht es weiter mit Chaosradio 190. Es geht um 3D-Drucker heute Abend. Und falls ihr Fragen oder Anmerkungen habt, seid ihr natürlich herzlich eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110.
Lauschen wir nun dem russischen Staatsüberhaupt Vladimir Putin. Wir übersetzen Simulant.
Nur ganz kurz zu der Frage, warum mein schönes Russland so etwas wie dieses Fritz unabhängig finanziert durch einen Rundfunkbeitrag auf gar keinen Fall braucht. Ganz einfach, solche unabhängigen Medien wie Fritz machen nur Ärger. Da kann man gar nicht in Ruhe regieren und regiert werden. Unser schönes Russland ist auch ohne sowas ein freies Land. Denn hier kann schließlich jeder machen, was ich will.
Und jetzt jubelt.
Fritz, unabhängig durch euren Rundfunkbeitrag. Einfach für alle.
Fritz-Info.
Nachrichten mit Martin Schneider.
Das Hochwasser hat in Niedersachsen ein erstes Todesopfer gefordert. Eine Frau, die in der Region Hannover auf einer überfluteten Straße mit dem Rad in den Flussleine getrieben worden war, ist im Krankenhaus gestorben. Sie war auf einer Straße unterwegs, die wegen Hochwassers gesperrt war. Auch in Sachsen, Sachsen-Anhalt, Thüringen und Bayern gibt es Hochwasser. Deutschland und Frankreich sind dafür, dass die Eurozone in Zukunft von einem hauptamtlichen Präsidenten geführt wird. Bei einem Treffen mit dem französischen Präsident Hollande hat sich Kanzlerin Merkel außerdem dafür ausgesprochen, Wettbewerbsfähigkeit, Wachstum und Beschäftigung zu fördern. Insbesondere müssten die EU-Gelder zur Bekämpfung der Jugendarbeitslosigkeit schneller verwendet werden. Mit dem Handy im EU-Ausland telefonieren und im Internet surfen, das soll in Zukunft nicht heurer sein als im Heimatland. So sieht es zumindest EU-Kommissarin Größ. Sie will die sogenannte Roaminggebühren komplett abschaffen. Sie könnten 2015 wegfallen, sollten Parlament und die EU-Staaten mitmachen. Erst vor knapp einem Jahr hat die Kommission die Kosten gedeckelt. Seit Juli 2012 dürfen zum Beispiel Anrufe innerhalb Europas maximal 35 Cent kosten. Russische Forscher haben in Ostsibirien Überreste eines Mammuts gefunden. Nach Angaben der Moskauer Wissenschaftler ist das Tier in einem sehr guten Zustand mit Muskelgewebe und flüssigem Blut. Die Wissenschaftler planen, das Mammut zu klonen. Die Überreste des jetzt entdeckten Mammutweibchens sind etwa 10.000 Jahre alt.
Wetter.
Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin Steglitz haben wir 16 Grad im Buch, sind es 18, Cottbus 14 Grad, Potsdam, Wittenberg, Angermünde 16, Neurupien 17 Grad. Heute Nacht gehen die Temperaturen auf 15 Grad runter, dazu gibt es eine Menge Regen, vor allem im Süden Brandenburgs und auch morgen bleibt es nass. Dazu gibt es immer wieder mal ein Gewitter und 22 Grad maximal. Drei Meldungen haben wir, die kommen aus Brandenburg. A2 Magdeburg Richtung Berlin, zwischen Wollin und Brandenburg an der Havel, da liegt ein Unterlegkeil auf der Fahrbahn. A10, südlicher Berliner Ring Richtung, nee nicht Richtung, Grasstätte am Fichtenplan Süd, in beiden Richtungen Vorsicht, da sind Personen auf der Fahrbahn. Und A12, Berlin Richtung Frankfurt oder zwischen Fürstenwalde, Osten und Briesen steht ein kaputtes Auto im Baustellenbereich. Da wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Chaosradio 190 ist hier mit Erdgeist, Micha und Pat. Und es geht um 3D-Drucker. Wo waren wir stehen geblieben?
Wir waren gerade dabei, zu ergründen, ob es eine große Revolution losbrechen wird, weil sich jetzt alle ihre Sachen zu Hause selber 3D drucken können.
Martin fragte gerade der Nachrichtensprecher, kann man eigentlich auch Schallplatten drucken?
Ja, kann man, aber der Drucker, die man dafür braucht, das ist wieder so ein professionelles Ding. Ich glaube von RobJet oder so, der kostet eine halbe Million ungefähr. Weiß nicht, kommt darauf an, wie groß die Platten-Sammlung ist.
Ja, aber für eine halbe Million kannst du deine Platten-Sammlung auch einmal komplett irgendwo rausschnorcheln aus dem Netz und dich dafür abmahnen lassen.
Erstmal muss man sie erst kennen. Damit man sie wieder drucken kann, muss man ja wieder einen freien Auflösungscanner haben.
Genau die Berge und Taylor auf der Brille.
Ich glaube, die Frau, die das gemacht hat, hat sich aus MP3s in Schallplatten umgewandelt. Das war der Trick. Sie hat aus diesen MP3s diese Audioform extrahiert, diese Wellenform und hat sich daraus ein Modell generiert. Und dann hat sie das gedruckt. So war das, glaube ich.
Das könnte tatsächlich revolutionär sein, noch so was.
Schallplatten drücken?
Die kommen sowieso wieder. In meiner Wahrnehmung kommen die gerade wieder. Du kriegst Schallplatten und dazu ein Downloadcode und dann hast du das Vinyl für die Ewigkeit und das MP3 zu mitnehmen.
Ja, und wenn das Vinyl bricht, machst du jetzt halt eine neue Platte.
Du kannst das Ugo dazwischen kaufen.
Aber als ich mir den Drucker gekauft hab und dann so rumprobiert hab, so eine kleine Revolution im Kopf hast du schon. Weil du fängst irgendwie an, dir Gedanken zu machen, wie so Sachen konstruiert sind. Es gab so einen Tag, wo ich praktisch angefangen hab, alles so in Schichten zu sehen.
Das kann ich ja auch mal.
Das kann ich ja auch mal. Damit hab ich in den 90ern aufgehört.
Das ist der Megamoment.
Das hat jetzt alles eine Z-Richtung. Und dann macht man sich halt Gedanken, wie so Sachen hergestellt werden und was man so richtig machen muss, damit es nachher stabil wird. Das ist schon ganz interessant. Das ist auch genau das, was passieren muss, damit die Leute drucken können. Wenn ich mir so eine Maus drucken will, dann kann ich das nicht einfach so machen. Ich muss erst mal ein 3D-Modell machen, was schon mal recht anspruchsvoll ist. Dann muss das auch noch druckbar sein. Dann muss ich mich wie mit Support-Strukturen befassen. Wenn ich da jetzt Brücken drucken will oder so. Dann muss das nachher noch maßhaltig sein. Dann kann ich vielleicht noch die Oberflächen veredeln. Da kann man eine ganze Menge Energie reinstecken. Wenn man das jetzt alles Stück für Stück so einfach macht, dass man praktisch seine Idee umsetzen kann, dann liegt es nur noch an der Idee und an der Ausarbeitung, die auch schon schwer ist. Wenn ich mir jetzt überlege, ich will mir jetzt irgendwas, ich habe jetzt irgendwie ein Bedürfnis und ich will dafür eine Lösung haben, dann muss ich jetzt mal eine Lösung finden. Bis ich mir jetzt alles drucke, was ich brauche, da brauchst du schon ein bisschen Ingenieursleistung ein.
Du musst genau andersherum denken, weil die Schalen an der Maus in Massenproduktion werden ja nicht gedruckt, die werden gegossen.
Vor allen Dingen solltest du sie mal aufschrauben, um zu gucken, was drin ist, weil es nicht mehr Plastik ist. Genau, und dann, weiß ich nicht, wenn du so mit Plastik druckst, erst mal anfangen dir zu überlegen, wo steht denn das am besten auf dem Boden, damit ich es drucken kann, und wenn ich jetzt so eine teure Sintermaschine zu Hause hätte, dann ist es schon ziemlich einfach. Da kann man echt beeindruckende Sachen machen. Also es gibt Firmen, die drucken so Maschinen oder so einen Automotor als Modell, der dann aber auch so beweglich ist. Die drucken halt in so einem Pulver, Schicht für Schicht, und dann holst du so ein Modell von so einem Motor, also von so einem Motorblock, mit Zylindern drin schon, alles drum und dran, holst den raus, staubst es aus, also irgendwie mit Luft gläst du das Ding aus, und dann kannst du dran drehen, und dann bewegen sich die Zylinder, und es funktioniert. Also da gibt es so einiges.
Und das drucken die in einem Stück?
In einem Stück, ja. Also wie auch Micha vorhin angedeutet hat, wenn du so anfängst, so mathematische, skurrile Objekte zu drucken, die so ineinander verschachtelt sind, oder wo was eine Kugel in einer Kugel ist oder sowas. Das kannst du halt wunderbar mit 3D Druckern machen und ganz schlecht mit irgendwelchen Spritzgussmaschinen oder sowas in der Industrie.
Ich bin gerade sehr fasziniert.
Also du kannst ja auch Sachen machen, die sonst nicht möglich sind.
Wir haben zwei Anrufer. 0331 70 97 101. Soll die unvermeidliche Frage kommen von Martin. Hallo Martin.
Hallo. Und zwar habe ich mal ein Video gesehen, da hat jemand so Teile für Waffen nachgedruckt, damit quasi diese Automatikfunktion noch da ist. Und da ist das irgendwann kaputt. Also es ist verbrochen, weil es ist halt nur Plaste.
Das ist Plaste und Explosion dazwischen, ne?
Genau, da wollte ich mal fragen. Also man hört jetzt halt so Waffen drucken, das geht ja wohl so einfach gar nicht.
Na, das ist irgendwie gerade der aktuelle Hype. Oh, hat's da ein Radio mal ein bisschen leiser machen?
Nee, das ist nicht das Radio, das ist die Leitung.
Oh, das ist gerade der aktuelle Hype, da Leute können sich ihren Kram selber machen. Waffen, Waffen, Waffen-Alarm ist halt genauso wie Internet und keine Ahnung, Kinderpornos, einfach so gerade der aktuelle Aufheizthema in den Medien ist einfach.
Weil es so schön plastisch ist, ne? Also das versteht das Volk auch gut.
Bloß wer Waffen bauen möchte, der nimmt sich, da gibt es irgendwie so von den exilierten Juden aus Israel, die nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg gesagt haben, ne, nie wieder, gibt so Bauanleitungen, wie geh zu deinem nächsten Klempner und nimm dir das und das Rohr und schweiß das zusammen, dann hast du eine brauchbare Knarre oder du gehst an den Baumarkt und kannst sowas basteln, da würdest du dir nicht die Mühe machen, das irgendwie aus dem Drainiedrucker fallen zu lassen. Das ist alles viel zu aufwendig.
Beziehungsweise kannst du es auch, das hab ich dann gelesen, jetzt auch in dem Zusammenhang mit dem Waffendruck aus Australien, da ist halt ein Typ hingegangen und hat gesagt, ich druck mir keine Kanone aus, ich kauf mir die einfach. Weil nämlich Einzelteile von Waffen zu kaufen, das glaubst du von den USA, Einzelteile von Waffen zu kaufen ist nicht verboten und unterlegt, keine Regulierung, keine Kontrolle. Du kannst also zu deiner AK-47 jedes Einzelteil kaufen gehen und die dann hinterher deine AK-47 wieder zusammenbauen und was fehlt, kannst du ja immer noch aus Plastik hinterherdrucken.
Jetzt kam ja zwischendurch diese Waffendiskussion auf in den USA und da hieß es denn, vollautomatische Waffen dürfen nicht mehr und dann haben sich halt Leute angefangen, mit einem 3D-Bedrücker da auseinanderzusetzen, ob das irgendwie möglich ist, so hatte ich es verstanden.
Die australische Polizei will ja auch tatsächlich eine Waffe gedruckt und abgefeuert haben und die ist denen angeblich um die Ohren geflogen. Was ich mir aber auch sehr gut vorstellen kann, dass sie einem um die Ohren fliegt, so ein Ding.
Wer ich die Polizei, würde es auf jeden Fall behaupten. Macht man nicht, ist voll gefährlich.
Ja, nee, aber das ist ja egal. Im Zweifelsfall druckst du dir halt irgendwie deine Waffe oder...
Im Zweifelsfall sagen sie auch, kauf keine China-Böller-Days, weil irgendwie...
Ja, du druckst dir den Lauf und machst dann da einfach mal irgendwie noch eine Metall-Armi-Rung drumrum und guckst mal, was da für Kräfte drauf wirken und so. Ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendjemand davon abhält, sich mal eben eine Wumme auszudrucken und auszuprobieren.
Und wenn es tatsächlich wirklich so gut funktionieren würde, dann wär es auch schon längst passiert.
Das wäre der beste Punkt. Das ist wie mit Zeitreisen.
Und gerade weil du ja natürlich Plastikwaffen natürlich auch nicht im Metalldetektor erkennen kannst. Deswegen für Geheimdienste natürlich 1A. Oder Terroristen.
Aber die machen das auch nicht mit Batydruckern.
Lohnt sich das ja dann aber doch irgendwie für so eine Art Einwegwaffe. So, feuerst dreimal ab und dann kannst du wegwerfen.
Ja, und dann hast du so ein bisschen Russisch Roulette, dass du dann einmal gehtst in der Hand oder doch?
Vielleicht.
Naja, was ja sicherlich denkbar wäre, wäre tatsächlich eine Waffe, die auch Kunststoffprojektile abfeuert über irgendeinen Federmechanismus.
Naja, vielleicht ist das aber schon tatsächlich fährlich genug, wenn man die Waffen einfach original nachdrucken kann. Anscheinend Waffen.
Kriegst halt auch bei eBay für ein Zwanziger, weißt du?
Das kommt aus China alles schon in einem großen Stil.
Mensch, so wenig klinge ich damit aus.
Kriegst du sogar bei Amazon? Verkaufen Sie die hier Softwarewaffen? Ich hab zu Hause eine MP5. Es sind halt kleine Plastikkugeln drin.
Aber du hast doch eine Maschinenperson, oder?
Solange du damit nicht zu Edeka gierst, mit Nachdruck noch mal.
Die hat 36 Euro gekostet, die hab ich gekauft, weil die hieß, warte mal, wie hieß die? Wie hieß das Ding? Nerd Begone oder so ähnlich? Also ein ganz sehr geiler Name. Ich recherchier das mal, macht ihr mal Radio hier.
Mach mal Show Notes, genau. Ja, und haben wir deine Fragen beantwortet? Oh, dann danke für deinen Anruf.
Ah, hier ist sie. Nerd Claire. Softair Sturmgewehr. 1666.
Oh, ist ja billig. Wie viel hast du dir geholt?
Was? Ich hab die auf meine Wunschliste getan und irgendwann war wahnsinnig genug mir das Ding zu schenken. Und ich kannte das überhaupt nicht. Softair-Zeugs waren mir völlig ungeläufig. Dann hab ich diese kleinen Plastikkügelchen... Ach so, Martin, ich sag mal Tschüss, schön Dank. Dann hab ich diese kleinen Plastikkügelchen da reingemacht und das Ding gespannt und dachte, mach ich ihn jetzt? Ich weiß gar nicht, auf was ich geschossen habe. Katze? Nee, ich hab keine Katze, sonst hätte ich die Katze genommen. Nachbarinnten? Nee, bei mir in der Wohnung. Und dann flog diese Scheißkugel als mehrfache Querschläger durch meinen Mund und irgendwann auf meinen Bein und hat wehgetan. Seitdem liegt das Ding im Schrank, weil ich dachte, das ist gefährlich. Aber kostet 16, 66 Euro und du hast eine Waffe, die aussieht, als wärst du von einer GSG 9 gerade. Brauchst ja auch nicht zu drucken, so ein Ding.
Holst du dir eine Stromhaube dann?
Bist du von einer GSG 9?
Oder bekommst du Besuch von einer GSG 9? Hast du noch einen Anruf?
Wir gehen davon aus, dass Waffen nicht druckbar sind. Jedenfalls momentan noch nicht und wenn dann unseriös.
Man kann's machen, aber man kann Waffen auch ganz anders herstellen. Das ist halt nicht so richtig voll spannend.
Da gibt's sowieso viele coole Dinge, die man machen kann. Und gerade Waffen gibt's irgendwie viel Forschung in anderen Bereichen. Laubsägewaffen und Sperrholzgewehr.
Angerufen hat der Kai, hallo Kai.
Hallo, wunderschönen guten Abend. Nur kurz ein, zwei Anmerkungen und zwar zur druckbaren Schallplatte, weil die genannt wurde, wenn man jetzt mal diese ganze leidige Waffendiskussion mal woanders hinschieben will, das funktioniert eh nicht. Ist das so, dass diese Platte wirklich funktioniert? Und zwar in einer Qualität, wir reden halt von 8 Kilohertz.
Ne, so genau funktioniert es, da rauscht es noch ordentlich drauf.
Ja, da rauscht es ordentlich. Also ich hab das Ding mir angeschaut und es rauscht ordentlich. Es funktioniert zwar, es gibt auch eine Open Source Community hat das gemacht, die dann entsprechend die Wafels zu dieser Platte konvertiert hat. Also man kann da so beliebiges drauf spielen, also nicht so, sondern nicht kompliziert. Und die haben dann einen entsprechenden STL-Style draufgemacht. Aber wie gesagt, die Qualität ist einfach trotz der relativ guten Drucker nicht wirklich brauchbar.
Also STL ist was?
Ist dieses Eingabeformat mit den 3DL?
Das ist ein Tessellation Language, das Teil. Und das ist dieses Eingabeformat. Das ist das Schweizer Format, das gebräuchlich ist bei 3D Druckern. Das andere ist der Step-File, FTP. Und das sind eigentlich die beiden gebräuchlichen Formate bei diesem ganzen 3D Druck.
Ich kann ja noch mal sagen, so ungefähr Genauigkeit von diesen professionellen 3D Druckern. Also die sind schon so im Mikrometerbereich.
Allerdings bitte nur in der Z-Richtung. Wir reden hier von der Schichtdicke. Die andere ist so ungefähr bei 1200 dpi mal 1200 dpi.
Für eine Schreibplatte halt immer noch zu wenig.
Zu wenig. Und darf ich auch noch mal ganz kurz erwähnen, das Object gehört inzwischen auch schon zu Stratasys. Da gab es eine ganz gewaltige Marktbereinigung. Die beiden großen Spieler, das sind 3D Systems und Stratasys, die haben praktisch den Markt unter sich aufgeteilt. Also alles, was jetzt auch SLS betrifft, ist praktisch bei 3D Systems. Und es hat unter anderem auch ein Open Source Projekt jetzt zu spüren bekommen, die jetzt einen SLS Drucker mal rausgebracht haben.
Du meinst den, sorry, den Form 1 meinst du?
Genau.
Okay, er ist kein Open Source Projekt, aber er ist ein Kickstarter Projekt, aber nicht Open Source.
Er ist ein Kickstarter, ist Kickstart von Projekten nach der Open, also License hab ich da mal gelesen. Gut, und zwar wäre was gelernt. Allerdings, die haben jetzt Probleme bezüglich, naja, sagen wir so der Patente.
Ja, weil halt 3D Systems beansprucht halt für sich, also stimmt ja, der Gründer von 3D Systems, ich glaub er heißt Chuck Hall oder so, der hat halt dieses SLA halt erfunden, also Stereolithographie, und der macht natürlich jetzt seine Patente halt gelten. Er hat dann halt 3D System gegründet, nachdem er das erfunden hatte, und ja, spielt jetzt ein bisschen Patent-Troll.
Also FDM-Patente sind ja inzwischen frei, also zumindest das Hauptpatent, das war ja der Herr Crump, der das eben erfunden hat, also auch wenn man das schon Namen nennt, der Gründer von Stratas ist, und deswegen ist das jetzt eigentlich endlich frei und damit auch verwendbar für jeden, dieses Patent mehr oder minder.
Obwohl die noch viele andere Sachen patentiert haben, zum Beispiel die Erzeugung von Stützstrukturen und so weiter, das ist auch, kannst du bei Google Patents, kannst du mal durchgucken, was die alles da in diesem, also Einzelverfahren vom FDM, Unterverfahren halt alles patentiert haben, also das ist schon krass.
Ja, sie sind halt auch schon seit über 25 Jahren in dieser, sagen wir so, Industrie tätig, nämlich was anderes ist das nicht, nämlich die Öffentlichkeit hat jetzt eigentlich erst in den letzten drei Jahren überhaupt Notiz von dieser Technik genommen.
Definitiv.
Wenn sie billig genug geworden ist.
Aber das ist ja mal spannend, da in der Historie mal ein bisschen rumzupropeln, wo das eigentlich herkam.
Wo kam das eigentlich her?
Wo kam das eigentlich her, weil so Schichten aufeinander zu kleben, früher haben sie ja so Roboter genommen, um eher so Kram abzuschaben von anderem mit Fräsen. Aber wie ging es denn da los mal mit?
Also das erste additive Verfahren war das Sintering. Also dieses mit Laser, also Pulver nehmen und dann Laser drüber, Schicht für Schicht und dann Objekt aushärten.
Kurz noch mal eine Verständnisfrage. Pulver nehmen und dann mit einem Laser drüber. Habe ich jetzt irgendwie eine Schicht Pulver gestreut und da fährt der Laser drüber?
Und dann muss ich das aus diesem Laser...
Das ist wie ein Würfel aus Pulver, durch das der Laser sich so durch...
Nee, also immer die oberste Schicht ist da, wo der Laser rüberfährt. Dann kommt eine neue Schicht drauf und dann wird wieder fest. Und dann habe ich irgendwann so einen Block aus Pulver und da drin ist dann das Objekt sozusagen. Muss ich dann rausholen und abwaschen.
Ah, okay, weil so ein Block aus Pulver, meine ich, nämlich schon mal irgendwo gesehen zu haben und habe mich die ganze Zeit gefragt, wie haben die das da reingekriegt? Okay, weiter, Entschuldigung.
Ja, und dann kam das Stereolithographie aus. Das ist so das Pendant, das 3D-Druck Pendant zum Laser-Cindering. Da startet man praktisch so eine Wanne aus Kunstharz und dann führt man den Laser über dieses Harz drüber, was dann aushärtet. Das ist so ein Polymerharz, was UV-härtend ist. Und dann kommt da halt das Objekt raus. Das war so das Stereolithographie. Und danach kam der, wie hieß er, dieser Scott Crump mit dem FDM-Zeugs, was eigentlich technisch relativ simpel ist, weil er halt, wie gesagt, das ist das mit der Wurst. Das versteht jeder.
Schon wieder Wurst gesagt.
Das ist aber auch intuitiv eigentlich. Machst du nicht auch zu Hause auch versuchen, so Schichten...
Nee, ich hab einen Tiefspüler.
Du machst sowieso schon noch in so einer Masse, in der das dann einfach so frei schweben kann.
Also ich erzeuge Kraft meines...
Schön, Holgi, danke.
Du hast angefangen.
Nee, angefangen hast du.
Nee, du. Das war schon kaputt. So, wo waren wir jetzt, Stingli? Jetzt mach mal weiter hier mit der Historie, bitte.
Das war so Ende der 80er als FDM. Da hat er das patentiert, Ende der 80er. Und 2029 dauert immer so ein Patentesystem ausgelaufen. Dann haben die Firmen da halt so ein bisschen, das wurde halt immer für Rapid Prototyping hauptsächlich dann benutzt. Dafür war es halt da.
Rapid Prototyping, erklär mal.
Rapid Prototyping ist halt, ich will zum Beispiel erstmal, ich will irgendein Produkt entwickeln. Und bevor ich da erstmal mir so eine fette, also dann soll es produziert werden, dieses Produkt. Und bevor ich mir so eine riesen Spritzgussmaschine mit einer fetten Fabrik hinbaue, probiere ich das halt erstmal aus und kaufe mir so einen Drucker. Und probiere erstmal, wie sich das anfühlt, wie die Haptik ist und ob das Produkt überhaupt den Anforderungen entspricht. Genau, das ging dann so ein paar Jahre dazwischen, weiß ich nicht genau, was passiert ist. Dann haben sich die 3D-Systems und Strata-Systems und Objets und haben wahrscheinlich auch große Umsatzgewinde in der Zeit gemacht, machen sie auch immer noch, also das boomt nach wie vor. Dann 2007 wurde dieses Riprap-Projekt in Angriff genommen. Das ist so ein Projekt, wo man halt 3D-Drucker wollen 3D-Drucker drucken.
Hatte der Postillion da nicht neulich so schöne Meldungen?
Ich muss sagen, ich finde den Postillion ja schon sehr lustig, aber wenn man den Artikel gelesen hat und so ein bisschen sich mit der Materie beschäftigt, war der Artikel...
Keine Satire mehr?
Ja, das war so. Ja, eigentlich wollen wir das ja in dem Riprap-Projekt. Und die machen halt auch FDM. Also ich weiß nicht, das Patent war irgendwie von Stratasys noch nicht ausgelaufen.
Was war FDM noch mal?
Fused Deposition Modeling, das ist, ich sag jetzt nicht, das Wort... Druckwurst, genau. Also wo halt ein Plastikfilament-Schlauch vorne mit einer Düse heiß gemacht wird und dann da durchgedrückt wird. Ja, genau, dann gab es halt dieses Riprap-Projekt und seitdem dann, also Open-Hardware-Printer und die haben das eigentlich populär gemacht, weil dieses FDM ist eigentlich relativ einfach als Verfahren. Wie gesagt, ich erkläre jetzt nicht noch mal, wie es funktioniert. Aber, das konnte man halt auch mit diesem Open Source, Open-Hardware-Zeug für 1.000 Euro oder 1.500 Euro so einen Drucker bauen lassen. Genau.
Teile davon drucken.
Genau. Also, dass natürlich auch Teile von dem Drucker selber gedruckt werden können. Die Elektronik kannst du natürlich nicht drucken, das geht noch nicht.
Ist das Wunschdenken oder geht es tatsächlich noch nicht? Also werden wir irgendwann in der Lage sein, zu sagen, ich möchte jetzt Platine 17?
Wir sind, also es ist, es könnte durchaus funktionieren. Also es gibt halt schon so Nanoscale Drucker. Ich weiß nur nicht, also muss man halt ein bisschen so Materialwissenschaften, ein bisschen Ahnung haben. Irgendwie ich bin da nicht so involviert drin. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, mit Graphäen oder sowas, dass man damit vielleicht so elektronisch, elektrische Schaltkreise mit drucken könnte.
Was war Graphäen? Das war irgendwie, das war der neueste Shit, ne?
Das war diese sechs hexagon-förmige Fläche aus Kohlenstoff, die dann so verbunden sind und dann so eine Struktur bilden.
Nano-Benzol-Ringe. Das ist Nano-Benzol.
Nicht Benzol, aber also praktisch cool. Wie Diamant, das ist ja 3D-Diamant und Graphäen ist halt so 2D Kunststoffschicht, ganz dünn.
Okay, 2D.
Aber wenn man so einen Drucker selbst drucken, also von einem Drucker drucken lassen will, dann hat das zwei Seiten. Auf der einen Seite guckt man natürlich, okay, was für Teile kann ich jetzt drucken? Also wenn ich jetzt meinen Drucker nehme, dann ist die Hälfte aus Holz und jetzt kann ich jetzt alles Plastik drucken. Aber man kann sich halt auch überlegen, wie baue ich einen Drucker, den ich drucken kann? Also, und da haben diese Riprap-Leute einiges gemacht. Die haben sich halt überlegt, okay, ich mach so einen Stangengestell. Die Stangen sind Gewindestangen, die kriege ich im Baumarkt oder auch überall auf der Welt. Und die Verbindungsstücke von diesen Stangen, um das Gehäuse zusammenzusetzen, die druck ich mir halt. Die sind halt in irgendwelchen Winkeln, haben Löcher drin, das schraube ich dann fest und so. Und dann habe ich halt schon mal so einen Gestell, auf dem das Ganze laufen kann. Und so versucht man halt einen Drucker zu bauen, der einfach, wo man viele Teile drucken kann. Und wir haben, in der Agentur haben wir einen Drucker, der ist ganz cool konstruiert. Das ist so ein Delta-Printer oder ein Delta-Bot, der besteht aus drei Z-Achsen, also drei vertikalen Achsen. Und die fahren, also die sind kombiniert, also die sind, von jeder der Achsen geht halt so eine Stange in die Mitte, beziehungsweise gehen zwei Stangen jeweils in die Mitte. Also man hat da vier Stangen, die in die Mitte greifen. Und in der Mitte ist der Druckkopf. Und indem man jetzt die drei Z-Achsen verschiebt, verschiebt man auch den Druckkopf in den horizontalen. Das sieht ganz weird aus. Irgendwie gibt es auch so eine Industrie bei Sortierrobotern und so. Und das ist ein Konstruktionsprinzip, wo wir, wo man also so ziemlich alles, bis auf das, was man nicht drucken kann, drucken kann. Also man kann halt immer das Gleiche nicht drucken. Na ja, ich kann keinen Motor drucken im Moment. Ich kann keine Platine drucken. Ich kann die Software darauf nicht drucken. Ich kann die Achsen nicht drucken, aber dann kriege ich halt Fehler rein, wenn die nicht ganz sauber sind. Deshalb kaufe ich lieber eine fertige Stange. Und bei dem Repair-Project geht es auch nicht nur darum, dass ich jetzt einen Drucker vollständig replizieren kann, sondern eher so ein bisschen darum, dass ich überall auf der Welt mit ein bisschen Material mir so einen Drucker herstellen kann. Und den Rest kaufe ich halt irgendwo im Laden.
Na, aber du brauchst erstmal einen Drucker, um das zu bootstrappen?
Klar, du musst halt erstmal Drucker haben, mit denen du die Teile drucken kannst.
Das ist wie Sauerteig so ein bisschen, wa?
Na ja, man gibt Zeit weiter, genau.
Kehfier.
Kehfier, es gibt doch noch so einen Pilz. Ist das eine Entwicklung, die schnell vorangeht, diese 3D-Drucker, oder ist das eher laslangsamm?
Na ja, es geht schon eine Weile lang.
Es sind jetzt schon 30 Jahre, immer so ein Moment, wo dann auf einmal so eine Technologie explodiert. Und es so ratzfatz geht.
Na ja, es gibt ja verschiedene. Weißt du, in Köln, in der Bibliothek, die haben sich so ein Ding gekauft, und da kannst du einfach hingehen und sagen, mit gerne, und dann kannst du dort einfach voll sozial, du gehst einfach hin und sagst, ich hab hier mein Modell, ich würd's gerne ausdrucken, und jeder kann dahin und muss sich nicht so ein teures Ding kaufen. Und das erste, was sie sich damit gedruckt haben, waren natürlich Dom-Modelle gewesen. Aber es ist halt so weit demokratisiert und auch an die Menschen wieder rangeführt, das kommt jetzt, glaub ich. Ich hab da so ein Gefühl.
0331 77 97 110 ist unsere Nummer.
Hallo. Wir sind aus Mitte und wir machen hier Mittwoch so ein kleines Community-Treffen. Das ist ein kleiner Hacker-Space. Und jeden Mittwoch drucken wir auch was. Wir haben jetzt mittlerweile den 3D-Drucker bestellt, der dann auch bei uns im Schaufenster rumsteht und vor sich hin druckt. Im Moment z.B. einen kleinen Hyper-Kubus, wenn wir das auch hören wollen. Weil das ist tatsächlich sehr interessant, wie sich die Dinge anhören.
Also, dass das Drucken des Hyper-Kubus sich anhört?
Ja, z.B. vielleicht kriegt man das...
Welcher Drucker ist es?
Das ist ein 3.1, aber wir haben auch...
Ich wollte raten.
Ich bin auch hier mit Rat, ne?
Entschuldigung.
Ruhe, lass doch mal hören.
Ja, warte hier. Hat man was?
Ja, aber es ist unspektakulär bisher so.
Ja, also wie gesagt, wir beschäftigen uns auch schon eine ganze Weile mit den Dingern und wir haben deswegen auch jeden Mittwoch ein kleines Treffen, also vom Team, aber auch von Interessierten. Und das ist offen für jeden ab 19 Uhr hier an der Hannoverischen Straße Nummer 3 in Mitte. Und ja, es geht immer um 3D-Druck und alles Mögliche mit der dazugehörigen Technologie.
Und wer seid ihr?
Ja, wir sind eigentlich ein kleiner Hacker Space slash Agentur. Wir machen auch natürlich so Webdesign. Aber unser Haupthobby ist der 3D-Druck und eigentlich auch unsere Vision ist, dass man in virtuellen Welten 3D-Objekte gemeinsam herstellt und die dann gegebenenfalls überall auf der Welt ausdruckt. Minecraft hat da zum Beispiel, ich glaube, das war heute gelesen, kann man jetzt auch tatsächlich was zusammenklicken und dann irgendwo ausdrucken. Aber ja, das ist auch unsere Vision, also dass man kollaborativ im Internet arbeitet und dann das lokal einfach ausdrucken kann. Und auch zum Verfolgen auch so ein bisschen die Idee von so einem 3D-Copy Shop, also dass man hier herkommen kann, sich gegebenenfalls tatsächlich einscannt und dann die Kopie mit nach Hause nimmt. Aber da sind wir uns alle einig, da sind wir noch eine ganze Ecke von entfernt. Tatsächlich? Ja, das wird leider noch ein bisschen dauern. Es gab mal so Künstler, die haben das gemacht. Ich glaube, es war in Frankreich, Paris, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, die haben tatsächlich auch so drei Xbox Kinect genommen und dann mit viel Handarbeit Passanten eingescannt und ausgedruckt. Aber das war alles im Zeitraffer nur zu sehen. Da kann man nur vermuten, wie viele Tausend Stunden da tatsächlich drinstecken. Aber theoretisch ist es möglich, die Praxis braucht leider noch ein bisschen. Ja, die Dinger sind halt, wie das schon durchklingt, die ganze Zeit, es ist tatsächlich so ein bisschen, man muss auch ein Hobby für entwickeln, wenn man sich tatsächlich ernsthaft damit auseinandersetzt. Und alles, was in die sogenannte professionelle Richtung geht, ist halt gleich wirklich sehr, sehr aufwendig. Aber ich denke auch, dass das jetzt bald mal noch viel besser wird. Und wir, gerade die nächste Generation der 3D-Drucker, ist ja wieder unterwegs, so wie der I3 beim Mendel. Da tut sich schon was. Aber richtig toll wird das sicherlich erst in ein, zwei Jahren. Aber bis dahin halten wir hier durch. Und wie gesagt, wir vermehren auch die Drucker fleißig. Also das ist... Den Rock-Drucker. Genau.
Das wäre für dich richtig toll.
Wir haben jetzt auch zum Beispiel so ein iRapid, da bin ich auch Fan von persönlich. Den gibt's schon ab 1000 Euro und die sind so fertig. Also das ist dann so richtig, so wie da steht. Im Schaufenster kann man ihn dann auch mitnehmen, einstecken und losdrucken. Und wir selber haben ja auch Bausätze zusammengesetzt und machen natürlich auch Workshops in der Richtung, aber für die meisten ist das dann natürlich viel besser oder doch spannender, dann direkt mit dem Problem loszulegen, wenn es darum geht, das Objekt tatsächlich herzustellen und nicht wie ich jetzt den Drucker herstelle, um dann Sachen herzustellen. Also insofern, wie gesagt, den iRapid, der ist schon ganz schnieke und der ist zwar ein bisschen kleiner, aber ich glaube, man nennt ihn Desktop 3D Drucker, ich weiß es nicht, wie die Klasse tatsächlich heißt, aber es ist zumindest mal, dass man nicht einen Bausatz hat, sondern wirklich schon ein fertiges Gerät.
Der heißt zwar iRapid, aber ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, als würden wir über doch relativ lange Druckzeiten sprechen, oder?
Genau, ja, der hat auch eine relativ kleine Düse, dadurch zwar eine schöne Auflösung, aber braucht natürlich ein bisschen länger als jetzt die Kollegen, die...
Wie lange druckt man denn jetzt irgendwie so ein Objekt von, was weiß ich, fünf Zentimeter Kantenlänge?
Fünf Zentimeter, also ich habe gerade diesen Hyperkurus ausgedruckt, der hat vier, aber das ist ja nicht wirklich... Ja, es kommt immer auf die Füllrate auch drauf an. Wie viel Luft kann ich da leisten? Wie viel Prozentfüllung gebe ich dem Ding jetzt? Und welche Füllung auch?
Ist das eher eine Frage von Minuten oder eher eine Frage von Stunden?
Eher von Stunden. Wir haben zum Beispiel die Fernsehfirme, die sind unser Dauerbrenner, die machen wir jetzt seit Jahren. Mittlerweile schaffen wir es auch, die tatsächlich auszudrucken. Das war immer, oh, das war sozusagen unser Test-File. Und wir sind jetzt sehr, sehr stolz, dass wir da eine Version haben, die sich jetzt sehen lässt. Im Übrigen, schöne Informationen. Die werden nur wirklich gut, wenn man zwei gleichzeitig druckt.
Wie eine Spitze, oder was?
Ja, eigentlich, weil sich die Hitze so sehr aufstaut im Turm.
Und dann hast du Probleme bei der Spitze oben, weil die dann nicht hart wird irgendwie.
Genau, also eigentlich fängt es schon in der Mitte an. Es wird relativ schnell zu heiß. Wie gesagt, wenn man dann zwei druckt, hat man da tatsächlich ein schöneres Ergebnis.
Wie einfach zwei nebeneinander, oder wie?
Genau, und dann wechselt man zwischen den beiden Modellen und dann hat jedes Modell für sich ein bisschen mehr Zeit abzugeben. Das Problem ist, wenn du als Spitze druckst, dann irgendwann druckst du halt heißes Zeug und es bleibt halt heiß. Und dann rührst du dann rum mit der Spitze und dann gibt es so eine Art Spirale. Ich hab da so ein Modell, da wollte ich auch mal so einen Print, der irgendwie, weiß ich, fünf, sechs Stunden dauern sollte, ein bisschen schneller machen und hab halt so ein paar Mechanismen da aus der Software rausgeschaltet, die das verhindern sollten. Und dann nach, weiß ich, immer noch drei Stunden oder so hat dann die Spitze, war dann halt Murks und ich kann das dann da wegschmeißen.
Der kleine Dom hat eh zwei Spitzen.
Ja und der Fernsehturm zum Beispiel, der ist glaube ich 18 Zentimeter hoch und das ist, haben wir optimiert, auf knapp 40 Minuten. Aber das ist schon Rekordzeit. Also da waren Modelle dabei, die haben ungefähr anderthalb Stunden gebraucht.
Ist das ein Geschäftsmodell? Also Fernsehtürme drucken in 40 Minuten und verkaufen?
Also wir verkaufen die Dinger zwar auch, aber da haben wir so ein bisschen die Preise erhöhen müssen, weil wir gesagt haben, hey für 15 Euro, das wird irgendwie doch nix pro Stück. Also man muss immer dazurechnen, dieser Drucker, der braucht einfach unglaublich viel Mühe, das am Laufen zu halten, der hat Verbrausteile, den muss man justieren. Das kam ja alles schon durch in der Sendung. Das ist sehr kompetent. Da merkt man schon, was da so drinsteckt. Aber ein richtiges Geschäftsmodell steckt da im Moment noch nicht dahinter. Wir stellen zwar diese Drucker aus und verkaufen die auch und beraten auch und machen auch Service und natürlich auch für Kunden. Wir haben auch das Fraunhofer-Institut schon Sachen entwickelt, aber wir sehen das eher langfristig. Also im Moment geht es tatsächlich darum, dabei zu sein und sich mit der Technologie auseinanderzusetzen. Und ich glaube da auch an eine Revolution, die wird sicher nicht heute oder morgen stattfinden, aber vielleicht nächstes Jahr.
Aber wie wird sie aussehen?
Naja, es ist ja relativ simpel. Ich meine, dass 1000 Millionen Stück mit einem Spritzgustteil herstellen, ist zwar very cost-effective, wie man so schön sagt, aber nur wenn man halt eine Million Stück braucht. Und die Welt und die Wünsche der Menschen sind halt nicht auf alles gleich, sondern wir wollen dann lieber Sachen, die mit Liebe und für uns persönlich hergestellt sind. Und dann werden sich die Mühe, die man sich machen muss, um dann ein personalisiertes Teil herzustellen, dann irgendwann auch lohnen. Und die Verfahren werden besser. Und die Drucktechnologien werden präziser. Also das ist nur eine Frage der Zeit, aus meiner Sicht.
Und die Technologie, die man benutzt, um irgendwas herzustellen, also das Funktionsprinzip, von dem man es dann herstellt, kann sich auch noch anpassen. Im Moment ist halt unsere ganze Technologie auf Spritzkurs angepasst und auf bestimmte Verfahrensweisen und so. Und das kann sich halt auch entwickeln. Also da gibt es halt so einige schlaue Ideen. Es gibt auch zum Beispiel so beim Lasercutten so Geschichten, wo man so eine Holzplatte flexibel macht, indem man lauter Schnitte reinmacht und so. Und dann ist es halt fast wie so ein Lappen auf der Hand.
Ich hab die mit Holz gedruckt übrigens.
Ja, so Holzfilament haben wir auch mal gedruckt.
Was wie Holz gedruckt?
Ihr solltet mich nicht überfordern. Dieses Material, das wir benutzen zum Drucken, nennt sich Filament irgendwie. Das ist eigentlich so eine Klebegeschichte, also so eine Schweißgeschichte, womit man Bodenbelag zum Beispiel verschweißen kann. Da gibt es jetzt Leute, die verschiedene Materialien anbieten. Wir haben verschiedene Farben. Mit Glitzer habe ich noch nicht was gedruckt, Gold und alles Mögliche kann man reinmischen, was giftig ist vielleicht auch. Es gibt auch ein Holzfilament, das ist Plastik gemischt mit Holz.
Sehr gemäht.
Genau, sehr gemäht, ganz fein irgendwie. Du druckst eigentlich auch Plastik, aber es gibt schon ein paar tolle Effekte. Erstens riecht es schön nach Holz. Dann lässt es sich super einfach drucken. Man hat auch einen riesen Vorteil, das hat eine wisse Textur, eine Ungleichmäßigkeit, die die Schichten verschwimmen lässt, sodass man das nicht so stark sieht. Das gibt auch bessere Ergebnisse. Sieht auch toll aus nach Holz, ist auch stabil. Eine coole Sache eigentlich. Ein bisschen empfindlich was Luftfeuchtigkeit angeht. Muss ein bisschen schwieriges Material.
Ja, sehr sogar, ein bisschen ledrig fast.
Es gibt auch flexibles Material, was irgendwie gummiartig ist, damit man einen Türstopper machen könnte, der flexibel ist. Da gibt es noch einige Sachen.
Da hab ich in Holland was gesehen. Der hat einen Silikonextruder entwickelt und hat damit tatsächlich eine Tasse gedruckt. Die war zwar sehr grobschachtig, also es war so richtig nur so Wurst. Ihr redet ja die ganze Zeit von Würst, aber das war mal eine Wurst.
Ihr habt jetzt alle in euren Köpfen.
Er hat eigentlich so eine Silikonkartusche unten aufgeschnitten und dann in den Extruder umgebaut, dass er das da rausdrückt. Und damit so eine kleine Tasse, also eine große Tasse gedruckt sogar. Und das war schon toll. Die konnte man gegen die Wand schmeißen und war immer noch wasserdicht.
War immer noch Wasser drin?
Ja, war drin nicht, aber es war zumindest erstaunlich, dass man da auch Silikon drucken kann, weil das ja eigentlich viel zu wässrig ist, um da was Ordentliches zu machen.
Aber der hat es geschafft.
Werden diese Geräte eigentlich billiger oder sind wir jetzt mit 1000 Euro, ist da die Talsohle erreißen, sie werden einfach nur immer besser für 1000 Euro?
Man sieht ja, dass die Kickstarter-Projekte, die tun ja alle so auf die 4 bis 600 Dollar-Grenze, so Zielen, ich denke, dass da Ende des Jahres sicherlich so was mit 5 bis 800 Euro ist man dann bestimmt dabei und das geht dann schnell.
Was kostet die Pumper eigentlich, die man da verdruckt?
Das wäre jetzt die nächste Frage, was kostet da für Materialkosten hat man da?
Das hat die geringsten Sorgen.
Ja genau, man holt so eine Rolle mit 2, 5 Kilo Plastik, kostet irgendwie so 50 Euro oder sowas. Und da droht man eine ganze Weile dran.
Und um nicht heiß zu machen, wie viel Strom verbrennt man?
Ja ordentlich, also das ist irgendwie so, ich glaube beim Ultimaker sind ein 12 Ampere Netzteil dran, also da fließt schon Strom. Ich hab's noch nicht gemessen, wie viel es genau ist, aber es ist sicherlich zu viel. Also das ist schon allein die Laufzeit.
Also wir verbrauchen also, wir verfatzen Strom, um die Welt mit noch mehr Plastik zu füllen.
Jetzt können wir nochmal an den Punkt mit der Revolution angreifen. Und das kam jetzt auch gerade von dem Zuschauer irgendwie, dass man, wenn man, Zuhörer, wenn man, wenn man jetzt nämlich nicht mehr anfängt irgendwie so millionenfach Zeugs zu produzieren, was man dann verticken muss und wo man denn Werbefilme machen muss, dass die Leute das auch kaufen und dann haben alle ganz viel Zeug zu Hause und probieren das alles aus, schmeißen die Hefte davon weg, sondern wenn sich halt jeder selbst Gedanken macht, was er wirklich braucht und nur das Druck, dann sieht die Welt halt ganz anders aus. Und dann ist vielleicht auch eben das doch ein bisschen, also vielleicht stellen wir dann einfach viel weniger Plastik her, Plastikzeug und können gezielter das einsetzen. Deshalb ist es auch für die Revolution wichtig, dass was in den Köpfen passiert. Also man muss halt wirklich auch mal mehr machen als nur Fernsehen gucken und sich was aussuchen, sondern muss sich halt mal was überlegen, was man braucht und so. Und das ist halt auch glaube ich ein Punkt, der überschritten werden muss.
Sehr schön immer mit den Druckgeräuschen auch im Hintergrund.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen Unterlegmusik hier.
Jan, vielen Dank. Und eine gute Nacht noch.
Bis bald.
Chaosradio 190 ist hier. Wollte ich einfach nur noch mal gesagt haben. Chaosradio 190 ist hier. Es geht um 3D Drucker und der Erdgeist der Micha und der Pat sind im Studio. Nur, dass ich es noch mal erwähnt habe, dass es in wenig heißt.
Ich glaube, was da gerade noch ein bisschen anklang im Hintergrund war, das Problem, diese Modelle zu machen. Also wer nicht Bock hat, da jetzt ewig rumzufummeln und zu forschen, sondern einfach so, ich hab da jetzt meinen Bauteil, das möchte ich haben und möchte da nicht Plasterausschuss für die nächsten 50 Jahre produzieren. Da braucht es einfach noch Werkzeuge. Gerade ist es noch echt mühselig, sich da so mal ein Modell dann wirklich am Ende auszudrucken, bis man gelernt hat, ja, dass man doch nicht in der Luft drucken kann und der Kram links und rechts runterfällt.
Was man ja eigentlich will, ist ein relativ günstiges, also was weiß ich, mittlere dreistelliger Preis, ein Drucker für zu Hause und eine Software, die in der Lage ist, das für solche Leute wie mich zu visualisieren.
So was wie das Workpress, ne?
Ja, so ein bisschen so, ja, irgendwie.
Visivik drucken.
Visivik drucken. Also bevor es das nicht gibt, wird sich das auch glaube ich nicht in die Fläche verbreiten.
Es gibt so Ansätze. Also es gibt zum Beispiel, kann man im Browser ausprobieren, Tinker Cat heißt das, das ist so ein kleines Cat-Programm, was auf ziemlich verspielte Art und Weise so komikhaft irgendwie dich so ein Modell zusammensetzen lässt. Das ist echt schon eine ganz tolle Sache eigentlich. Ist glaube ich gerade auch von Auto Cat irgendwie oder sowas aufgekauft worden. Und die haben halt so einen Ansatz, das wirklich so verspielt rüber zu bringen. Man bringt halt so ein, man setzt einen Cube hin, also einen Würfel hin und nimmt einen Zylinder und dann zieht man die von der NAB und dann hat man ein Loch in dem Würfel und so weiter und so fort. Und wer da Spaß dran hat, sich da durchzufummeln, der kann damit auch ziemlich leicht so ein Modell machen. Punkte sind so, dass man halt trotzdem überlegen muss, wie man das konstruiert und das ist halt eben so ein bisschen Ingenieurswissen halt, also wie wenn ich nachher Teile zusammenbauen will, die müssen passen, die müssen, ich muss das drucken können, ich kann jetzt nicht, neulich kam jemand an und wollte so ein Laptop-Imitat drucken und ist halt einfach ein bisschen groß und dann muss man das halt aus mehreren Teilen machen und so und sind ein paar Hürden zu überwinden.
Ah, das ist noch spannend. Wie groß ist denn so das größte Teil, was da so auf so einen 3D-Drucker drauf passt?
Also was ich jetzt gelesen habe, irgendwie wurde in Japan gerade glaube ich, war das so ein, oder was, ich weiß nicht, irgendwo in Asien auf jeden Fall. Da haben sie so einen riesen Teil aus Titan gedruckt, irgendwie das größte Teil, was man bisher gedruckt hat irgendwie. Aber zu Hause hast du so eine Größenordnung von 20 x 20 x 20 cm, das ist so üblich. Es gibt auch diese Desktop-Drucker halt, diese kleineren, die eher so, weiß ich, so 10 x 10 cm haben. Man kann es aber auch größer machen. Das ist ein bisschen problematisch, weil man hat viele Achsen, die über das ganze Gerät gehen und wenn die halt zu lang wären, dann wird es halt ungenau, dann muss man halt wieder bessere Teile benutzen. Und von daher sind Grenzen gesetzt. Aber prinzipiell kann man damit auch Häuser drucken, macht man auch. Ja, Häuser und Mauern drucken. Ich habe neulich so ein Video gesehen von so einem Laden, die drucken halt Mauern. Also die haben halt irgendwie so, die kommen, es gibt halt die Variante, die sie so im Prospekt haben, ist halt die, die kommen halt angefahren mit ein paar Tiefladern, legen dann halt irgendwie zwei Schienen an den Seiten von dem Grund, wo das Haus gebaut werden soll. Und da kommt halt so ein Schlitten rauf, der fährt dann hoch irgendwie mit einer Achse oben drüber. Und da ist dann ein Druckkopf und der druckt dann die Mauern.
Richtig dicke Wurst.
Genau, eine richtig dicke Betonwurst. Und das funktioniert ganz gut.
Was wird dann hinterher runtergeschliffen?
Nee, also erstmal das Material auftragen.
Bindemittel ist da drin. Also immer Sand, Bindemittel, Sand immer abwechselnd pro Schicht. Und dann wird das so hart. Ich weiß gar nicht, laut dieser Firma braucht man auch keine Metallstangen. Kein Stahlbeton oder so. Das ist so hart, dass es halt so hält.
Na gut, in Japan sind die Häuser nur für 10 Jahre konzipiert. Dann reißen sie sie wieder ab.
Geplante Obsoleszenz für Häuser.
Also prinzipiell steht nichts im Wege. Warum sollte man nicht auch eine Mauer drucken können? Wenn man jetzt so eine Betonbauer mit Verschalung gießt, ist es im Prinzip das gleiche. Man muss halt nur das Material anders einnehmen. Ja, man muss halt einen Hightech-Beton nehmen, der schnell trocknet oder zumindest fest da stehen bleibt, bevor er austrocknet und so. Aber da muss man halt an vielen Rädern noch drehen und dann geht es bestimmt ganz gut. Wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, eine Baustelle, die hat heute drei, vier Mitarbeiter, einer als Kranführer und die restlichen arbeiten zu oder so. Und dann, wenn man da jetzt so eine Maschine stehen hat, kann man sich eine Menge Zeit, also eine Menge Zeit einfach die Maschine arbeiten lassen. Und das vielleicht auch leiser als irgendwie rumzuhämmern oder so. Also da sind schon ein paar tolle Möglichkeiten.
Auch da würde ich gerne mal sehen, wie lange das dauert, bis so eine Mauer fertig ist.
Das geht recht flink, da kann man sich auch im Internet angucken. Das geht echt schnell, da habe ich echt gestaunt. Und jetzt hat ja die NASA überlegt irgendwie so, wir wollen jetzt mal auf den Mond bedrucken, mit habitalen Strukturen, wo unsere Astronauten hinfliegen können und wohnen können dann. Und da ist die Idee, dass man dann einfach das Material vor Ort nimmt, den Mondstaub, wenn er nicht schon ganz fein ist, und den dann irgendwie bindet und dann damit so eine Kuppel baut und dann können die da halt einziehen.
Das wäre ja mal geil.
Also schickst du halt auch zum Mars, könntest du halt irgendwie jetzt so erstmal ein paar so 3D-Touren reinschicken. Die machen dann erstmal so eine kleine Stadt oder so die Grundstruktur und dann gehst du da hin und ziehst da halt ein, kriegst eine Schlüsselübergabe.
Und wenn du dann ankommst, haben sie sich Waffensysteme gebaut und...
Du kommst ja nicht auf unseren Planeten. 0331 70 97 110 ist unsere Nummer. Es geht um 3D-Drucke heute Abend. Und der Thomas, dem ist auch noch was eingefallen, was man drucken könnte. Hallo Thomas.
Guten Abend. Mir ist eingefallen, dass wir ja so Verschlechtsspiele, Monopoly und und und, da liegen ja sehr viele Plastikteile bei. Und wer weiß, vielleicht druckt man sich die in Zukunft und kauft das Spiel nicht mal im Laden. Und das wird sicher noch die nächste Urrechtsschlacht werden, wer da ein Recht dran hat. Überhaupt nicht.
Das ist Gegenwart. Also zum Beispiel jetzt Siedler von Katarn. Irgendwie ist so ein Beispiel, da kann man sich halt irgendwie die Metropole und die Häuser drucken irgendwie. Und dann gibt es halt so rechtliche Geschichten, was so Gebrauchsmusterschutz und was auch immer. Aber das zum Beispiel in dem Fall von dem Siedler von Katarn, da sind diese Häuser sind halt ziemlich simpel wie bei Monopoly. Und die sind halt so simpel, dass man die halt auch einfach drucken kann, weil die kann man halt nicht schützen.
Klar, die erreichen nicht die Schöpfungshöhe.
Genau.
Ja, Mickey Mouse ist dann so ein Urheberrechtsding.
Ronald McDonald.
Das Ding ist, ich kann ja mit einem 3D-Drucker nicht nur irgendwie Musik, Film und so weiter, das ist ja alles schöne Künste dieser Bereich. Aber ich kann ja mit dem 3D-Drucker halt auch Nutzgegenstände drucken.
Stimmt, da hat ja im Zweifelsfall auch irgendjemand Rechte dran.
Genau, das ist in der Designer-Community gerade das ganz heiße Ding. Die können gerade Nerven zusammenbrauchen. Ja, die selbe Geschichte wie mit Musik. Das war vor 15 Jahren, dass wir die ersten an die Herz und Farbe bekommen haben. Dann als die ersten Exekutive von den Filmstudios gehört haben, wie schnell die SL-Leitungen jetzt sind, sind die da auch aus den Meetings rausgerannt und mussten schnell telefonieren. Und die Designer, die vorher noch zu einer großen Manufaktur gegangen sind und gesagt haben, hier nimm mal meinen tollen Löffel. So kann man jetzt aus dem Interweb runterladen und sich selber zu Hause Löffel machen. Und sogar noch, wenn einem der Löffel von dem Designer fast ganz gut gefallen hätte, außer das Ding da hinten. Noch ein bisschen nachjustieren. Dann hat man irgendwie seine eigene. Das ist ja auch geil, wenn man früher die Partina an seinem selbstgemachten Holzlöffel hatte, dann hat man jetzt die Versionsgeschichte seines Löffels auf den Server für alle zum Ankieken. Genau wie man ja auch die Plattensammlung nicht mehr im Schrank stehen hat, sondern so hier ist meine MP3-Sammlung und auf dem Screen da hinten sind die Albumcover, die da durchscrollen oder so.
Das ist natürlich auch aus Produzentensicht muss man umdenken, statt wie du schon gesagt hast, der Designer kann dann halt nicht mehr zur Firma gehen und da seine Dienstleistung anbieten, sondern muss halt gucken, dass er seinen Löffel-Design so an den Mann bringt. Im Grunde wie hier Radio und Podcasts. Auf einmal muss man nicht mehr zu einem Sender gehen und sagen, bitte nimm mich doch, lass mich doch senden bei dir. Sondern man macht es halt selber. Und verdient dabei aber nicht mehr so gut.
Da ist ja noch ziemlich, wenn du so Designer bist, dann bist du ja nicht auch gleich Statiker, oder keine Ahnung, sondern hast dir irgendwas ausgedacht, eine tolle Form, die dann vielleicht auch hält. Und dann musst du mit irgendjemandem sprechen.
Klar, aber was es macht, es verändert halt einfach Einkommenstrukturen. Also wo du dich vorher drauf verlassen konntest, ich geh da hin, jetzt hier, Hörfunk, ich geh zum Hörfunk, mache hier meinen Job und bekomme dafür eine definierte Summe Geld, von der ich leben kann. Das hab ich bei Podcasts nicht unbedingt. Also wenn du jetzt sagst, ich will gerne Radio machen.
Na Dienstleistungspodcast macht doch hier Tim, macht doch welche für die Luft- und Raumfahrt-Dings.
Da funktioniert er auch. Das ist dann ja wieder das alte Prinzip, wie beim Radio letztlich, dass du einen großen Auftraggeber hast, der dich finanziert.
Nö, da sind mehrere.
Ja.
Aber es ist halt alles nicht in diesem Größenordnung.
Ich finde das ganz interessant, weil auch da muss ein Umdenken stattfinden. Da wird gerade auch bei Medienproduktion umgedacht und dann eben bei Produktproduktion.
Die sind aber auch generell ziemlich helle und nette Leute und die gehen da schon progressiv mit um.
Tatsächlich?
Ja, wenn man ein bisschen mehr Marktmacht hat, dann kann man sich seine Designs auch als Gebrauchsmuster schützen lassen für 25 Jahre. Wie die Deutsche Bahn, die sich zum Beispiel den ICE hat schützen lassen. Also liebe Kinder, wenn ihr ICEs druckt, nicht verkaufen, sonst kommt die Bahn und nimmt sie euch weg.
Das ist auch ein spannender Punkt, weil für den Eigengebrauch kann man sich den Kram natürlich auch runterladen, solange das Kinder merkt.
Du darfst halt fotografieren, was du willst, du darfst es halt noch nicht veröffentlichen.
Nokia hat ja auch mal versucht jetzt irgendwie so mit Covers, also für Handys, so Handy-Cover offensiv ranzugehen und die haben halt irgendwie so Daten angeboten, wie man so einen Cover druckt, dann kann man sich das halt selbst drucken. Das ist halt auch eine Idee, also man kann da auch anders rangehen, man muss nicht immer alles verbieten, man kann da auch mit arbeiten letztendlich. Da haben die Leute ja Spaß daran, sich das anzupassen.
Es gibt nur noch keine Lobbygruppe, die versucht, das verbieten zu lassen, weil sie es noch nicht mitbekommen haben? Oder weil die Designer wirklich cooler sind als die anderen?
Ich glaube halt, dieser Napster-Moment, also so wie bei MP3, dieser Napster-Moment hat noch nicht stattgefunden.
Es gibt jetzt 3D-Daten, auch auf Pirate Bay, haben sie gesagt.
Aber es ist noch nicht so, dass sich irgendeine Industrie dadurch so bedroht fühlt, dass sie jetzt mal mit der rechtlichen Keule richtig hart ausschlagen.
Weil ich es noch nicht benutzen kann. Der Napster-Moment war ja, ich konnte mir auf einmal völlig problemlos MP3s besuchen.
Aber du kannst ja zu jemandem gehen, der einen Drucker hat und dann geht das schon.
Dafür ist es noch nicht billig genug, das auszudrucken. Und eigentlich ist ja für dich der Nutzen erst in dem Moment, wo du wirklich Custom-Teile für dich herstellst. Und dafür brauchst du ja entweder jemanden, der wieder als Dienstleister dieses Custom-Teil macht. Du musst gucken, ob sie dir für dich lohnen. Oder die Werkzeuge sind so einfach, dass die Custom-Teile für dich keinen Aufwand mehr machen. Aber da gibt es spannende Entwicklungen. Es gibt gerade heute auch beim Stöbern noch wenige Funden, der so Schmuck einfach zum Selber machen. Es gibt so halb 30 Drehregler, an denen du dir Fingerdurchmesser, Formen, so kleine Juwelen dort so einfach nachher regeln kannst. Und dann fällt dann auch so ein druckbares Format raus. Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht welches. Aber heißt so Open Jewels. Und machen sich Leute auch jetzt Gedanken darum, irgendwie dir dann am Ende als Holgi zu Hause, ich will meinen eigenen Kram da machen.
Einen eigenen Plastikschmuck haben.
Was da so geht, da muss man einfach nur mal zu den Computerspielen gucken. Wenn man so jetzt so ein Character Editor hat, für irgendwie seinen Charakter an so einem Spiel oder so, dann dreht man da auch an Regeln rum. Und dann verändert sich das Gesicht. Und dann kann man halt hier noch was klicken und da noch ein Tattoo drauf und so. Und ja, so kann man das halt sich auch vorstellen für bestimmte Anwendungszwecke. Und wenn man da ein bisschen dran bastelt, dann kann man schon ein bisschen Software bauen, womit man schon eine Menge machen kann. Also was sich zum Beispiel Schrauben drucken oder was auch immer. Also Standardteile, die man einfach nur skalieren muss oder wo man ein paar Parameter angeben muss, ist halt recht simpel. Das ist sowieso, also parametrisierbare Teile sind sowieso so ein Ding irgendwie. Also du kannst halt irgendwie dir ein Modell machen, wo du was verändern kannst. Also du kannst es erstmal skalieren, du kannst aber auch, zum Beispiel bei diesem Zahnbustenhalter, da habe ich dann letztendlich ein Modell rausgekriegt oder ein kleines Programm rausgekriegt, wo ich die Anzahl der Familienmitglieder einstellen kann. Und dann kann ich mir halt, wenn ich einen Drucker habe, der groß genug ist, auch einen Ständer drucken, der halt für 10 Zahnbusten funktioniert. Und dann ist es halt für jedermann ganz einfach. Das stelle ich halt ins Internet und jeder lädt sich so runter und sage ich, okay, wir sind zu fünft, zack, und dann kann man das halt drucken. Und auf dem Niveau kann man da schon eine Menge machen. Aber es ist auch für große Firmen, die jetzt hier so 3D-Druck machen, ein Riesenproblem. Die Dateneingabe ist immer noch schwierig. Und es gibt da so eine Firma, die 3D-Druck machen in Holland, Shapeways, und die haben zum Beispiel so auf die Ideen gekommen, ein Soundfile als Eingabe zu nehmen und dann zum Beispiel das auf einen Handycover hinten drauf zu machen als Struktur und so dieses Problem ein bisschen zu lösen, dass keiner so 3D-Daten erzeugen kann von sich aus. Man nimmt dann einfach irgendwelche anderen Daten oder ein Foto und macht daraus ein Relief oder so. Das geht halt auch schon.
Aha, bei den Computerspielen fallen ja diese 3D-Modelle auch an. Ich stelle mir gerade vor, dass es einfach mal noch ein geiler sekundärer Markt wäre. Du hast da so riesige Herrscher von Leuten, die da für deine Games und alle möglichen Kramen modeln. Warum diese Models dann nicht hier im Spar-Abo für, keine Ahnung, zum Zuhause selber drucken oder fräsen oder irgendwas? Dann nimm und mach bunt.
Da schlägt dann aber auch wieder das Urheberrecht zu.
Also vor allem, wenn du die Firma bist, dann sagst du einfach hier, ja okay, da sagst du meine Webseite runter.
Aber wahrscheinlich, vielleicht denken die dann auch irgendwann um. Es gibt ja auch immer noch kein, also gibt's ein gutes Filmportal, wo man sich so mal Filme für 5 Euro runterladen kann. Pirate Bay.
Was für Drucker gibt's denn jetzt eigentlich?
Eine Menge.
Ich weiß jetzt, wie hieß der iRapid genau? iRapid hieß er, den kann ich mir kaufen. Und der ist halt so, dass zumindest ich den auch in Betrieb genommen kriege. Da kommt dann hinterher zwar auch nur dieselbe blaue Wurst raus, die ich vorne reingegeben habe, aber immerhin.
Also es gibt so eine, ich hab so eine Liste gesehen, mit weit über 100 Druckern inzwischen, die so verfügbar sind, unter, was war der höchste, glaube ich, 10.000 Euro oder so. Dann gibt es halt so ein paar, also so 5.000 Euro und so. Die große Menge ist aber unter, sagen wir mal, 3.000 Euro. Und da geht schon einiges. Und am unteren Ende, da passiert im Moment nicht viel, weil man braucht immer die gleichen Teile für fast alle Drucker. Man hat halt irgendwie vier Motoren und ein paar Achsen und ein paar Riemen und so. Und das Zeug muss man immer noch kaufen.
Warum eigentlich vier Motoren? Würden nicht drei auch reichen?
Ja, es ist ja 3D und dann muss man halt noch die Wurst managen. Also man hat dann dieses Plastik, diesen Plastikdraht, den man da reinschiebt, der muss halt irgendwie transportiert werden und das ist halt der vierte Motor. Ganz entscheidend auch.
Thomas hängt immer noch in der Leitung. Warum sagst du eigentlich nichts, Thomas?
Ich wollte euch reden lassen. Aber ich studiere persönlich Maschinenmauer, also komme aus jeder Richtung. Und wir haben halt eine Führung mal in unser Konstruktionstabor bekommen. Und die haben halt so einen professionellen Sinterdrucker. Und der kann halt verschiedene Farben drucken. In einem Objekt. Die haben da so einen kleinen Otto-Motor mal gebaut. Und da waren dann verschiedene Teile verschiedener Farben. Das sieht richtig geil aus.
Die drucken wahrscheinlich, also die sind dann mit Bindemitteln wahrscheinlich. Das heißt, da wird normalerweise so eine Art, also ziemlich genau ein Tintenstrahldruck-Kopf drauf, der irgendwie so ein, nicht? Oder?
Ich hatte ja nicht erklärt. Also der hat das nur bezeichnet. Aber mit eure Softwareprobleme, ich hab vor ein paar Jahren mal so einen Kurs, bin ich in der VHS, auch überschreitet mit Prototypen. Und das war halt ein richtiger Krampf, das aus dem professionellen CAD-Programm in das Tool rein zu bekommen, weil die Hersteller von dieser professionellen Software sich bis heute nicht auf ein Format geeinigt haben, was irgendwie alle Daten überträgt. Man muss dann gucken, ob da alle Kanten geschlossen sind oder ob das Ding irgendeine Lücke gelassen hat.
Das ist auch elend viel Mathematik. Das ist nicht so wie Betriebssysteme machen, wenn man da Kernelhacker ist, dass man da Spaß dran hat, sondern das ist einfach wirklich echt stupide Arbeit und so was zu programmieren. Das wollen sich die Leute dann irgendwie auch vergülden lassen. Und da haben echt wenig Leute Spaß da in dem Bereich einfach dann Open Source Software herzustellen.
Dann ist genau das das Geschäftsmodell.
Und es gibt auch halt auch mehrere Arten, wie ich halt ein 3D-Objekt beschreiben kann. Und für jetzt zum Beispiel Spiele und so, Charakter sind halt Dreiecke total cool, weil ich die total cool animieren kann. Wenn ich jetzt aber ein 3D gedruckt...
Nee, weil Grafikkarten das echt schnell darstellen können.
Und das auch, ja. Aber auch die Animationen sind halt relativ einfach, im Gegensatz zu voxeln, weil es ist immer noch so ein... Voxel ist ein dreidimensionaler Pixel. Und das ist halt für 3D-Drucken eigentlich das, was man eigentlich so haben möchte, weil man kann im Prinzip dann für jeden Punkt in diesem Objekt kann man dann festlegen, was da passieren soll. Wie viel Material da rein soll, und ob da welche Farbe usw. Das ist so, was man möchte. Aber eigentlich sind alle CAD-Programme, eben weil auch die Grafikkarten so schnell sind. Und sind eigentlich alle auf diese Dreiecks-Modellierungen ausgerichtet. Auch dieses STL-Format, was wir vorhin angesprochen haben, ist ja auch nur ein Dreiecke, wie ich halt diese Struktur beschreibe. Da kann ich halt nur außen sagen, okay, da kann ich nicht mal Farbe beschreiben. Ich kann nur das Dreieck reingeben. Die Farbe muss ich dann theoretisch von einer anderen Datenquelle noch irgendwie bekommen. Da gibt es auch noch erweiterte Formate mittlerweile, additive manufacturing Formate, das ist ein neuer Standard.
Die Dreiecke sind dann flach, ne? Wenn ich dann irgendwie eine...
Flach und hohl, ja.
Also ich brauche also drei Dreiecke, um eine Pyramide bauen zu können, damit ich überhaupt einen Körper habe.
Genau, vier Dreiecke.
Du machst ja wie zwei Dreiecken, wieder ein Quadrat oder ein Altquadrat.
Ach ja, du brauchst ja noch eine Basis der Pyramide.
Genau, und die muss halt geschlossen sein. Das ist so eine Anforderung, die dieses Mesh haben muss.
Da gibt es halt Rundungsfehler, was sich alles passieren kann, dass da doch eine Lücke entsteht. Und dann kann so ein Slicer-Programm, was versucht, diesen Code dazu zu erzeugen für den Drucker, einfach mal abstürzen oder so, kommt halt auch vor.
Wir machen mal Nachrichten. Thomas, danke für deinen Anruf. Gute Nacht, tschüss und ihr bleibt bitte hier. Is grad Silvester? Um 23.31 Uhr Organe drucken? Was sagen die mir hier? Hier?
Die Berliner Grundschulen sollen sicherer werden. SPD und CDU haben im Berliner Abgeordnetenhaus vorgeschlagen, dass jede Grundschule einen Kooperationsvertrag mit der Polizei schließen solle. Außerdem sollten die Schuleingänge während des Unterrichts verschlossen und Videokameras eingesetzt werden. Kritik an den Vorschlägen kommt von den Grünen. Sie befürchten, dass die Schulen zu Hochsicherheitstrakten gemacht würden. Das Geld solle besser in mehr Sozialarbeiter, Psychologen, Lehrkräfte und Aufsichtspersonal investiert werden. Wegen des starken Dauerregens gibt es in mehreren Bundesländern Hochwasser. Mancherorts sind die Flüsse schon über ihre Ufer getreten. In Niedersachsen gibt es ein erstes Todesopfer. Eine Frau, die auf einer überfluteten Straße mit dem Rad in den Flussleine getrieben worden war, ist im Krankenhaus gestorben. Hochwasser gibt es zurzeit auch in Sachsen, Anhalt, Thüringen und Bayern. Deutschland und Frankreich sind dafür, dass die Eurozone in Zukunft von einem hauptamtlichen Präsidenten geführt wird. Bei einem Treffen mit dem französischen Präsident Hollande hat sich Kanzlerin Merkel außerdem dafür ausgesprochen, Wettbewerbsfähigkeit, Wachstum und Beschäftigung zu fördern. Insgesamt müssten die EU-Gelder zur Bekämpfung der Jugendarbeitslosigkeit schneller verwendet werden. Ne, eigentlich nicht. Eine weitere Nachricht haben wir aber noch. Russische Forscher haben in Ostsebirien Überreste eines Mammuts gefunden. Das ist auch großer Sport. Nach Angaben der Moskauer Wissenschaftler ist das Tier in einem sehr guten Zustand mit Muskelgewebe und flüssigem Blut. Die Wissenschaftler planen, das Mammut zu klonen. Die Überreste des jetzt entdeckten Mammutweibchens sind etwa 10.000 Jahre alt. Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Steglitz haben wir 16 Grad im Buch, sind es 18 Forst, 13 Grad Prenzlau, 14 Potsdam, 15 Pritzweig, 16 Grad und Neurofin noch 17 Grad. Heute Nacht geht es bis auf 15 Grad runter. Dazu gibt es jede Menge Regen, vor allem im Süden Brandenburgs. Da kann es dann auch ein paar Unwetter geben. Morgen geht es dann nass weiter. Mit weiteren Gewittern müsst ihr rechnen. Das Ganze bei maximal 22 Grad. Da gibt es zwei Meldungen, die kommen aus Brandenburg. Einmal von der A12 Berlin Richtung Frankfurt oder zwischen Fürstenwalde Ost und Briesen. Da steht ein kaputtes Auto im Spaustellenbereich. Und A13 Dresden Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Starco und Barothmarck steht ein kaputter Bus auf dem Standstreifen. Da wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wenn ihr den Fritz Night Flight von letzter Nacht verpasst habt oder ihn einfach nochmal hören wollt, dann hört ihn doch einfach nochmal. So oft ihr wollt und wann ihr wollt. Eine Woche lang im Musikstream. Musikstream auf FritzD.
3D Druck im Chaosradio 190, Erdgeist, Micha und Pat im Studio. Und sagt Pat so kurz vor Nachrichten, über Bio-Printing können wir noch reden, also Organe drucken und so. Darf ich eine, ich hatte jetzt eine qualifizierte Nachfrage.
Also muss ich das mal belegen. Bisher tauschen wir irgendwie Organe von Halbtoten oder toten Leuten, irgendwie nehmen die raus da und packen die anderen Leute rein. Und es gibt eine Menge Probleme, man muss eine Menge Medikamente schlucken, damit die nicht abgestoßen werden. Und schon seit einer ganzen Weile sind Mediziner und sind da dran, irgendwie Organe zu drucken oder herzustellen. Und das gibt es auf verschiedene Art und Weisen. Das ist alles sehr kompliziert, weil die Strukturen in diesen Organen sehr kompliziert sind und weil die Zellen am Leben sind. Man muss die halt in einem Milieu halten, wo sie den Druck überleben. Man muss die halt irgendwie mit Blut versorgen. Also wenn du so ein Organ hast, da sind ja Adern drin und so. Und die musst du halt alle irgendwie drucken. Und so, dass auch noch her die Zellen nicht absterben, das ist ein riesiges Problem. Und womit man angefangen hat, ist irgendwie, man hat zum Beispiel, ich glaube, das ist nicht direkt 3D drucken, aber man hat halt irgendwie so ein Schweineherz und spült es halt aus, die ganzen Zellen raus und hat dann nur so die Fasern und dann kommen da Stammzellen drauf und dann wächst da halt wieder so ein Herz und dann kann man es auch zum Pumpen wiederbringen. Das ist halt so eine Variante.
Und ist das schon gemacht worden oder ist das schon gemacht worden?
Da gibt es auch Leute, die so eine Organe drin haben und die leben und die leben damit ganz gut, weil die Stammzellen kommen von ihnen selbst. Das heißt, da sind weniger Abschlussungsreaktionen und so weiter. Und Ziel ist es, das Zeug richtig zu drucken, aber eben weil eben so Organe komplizierter sind, ist es halt schwierig.
Also mit Knorpelgewebe geht das halt ziemlich gut. Gerade so Herzklappen und auch Knorpelspeiseröhre und so was. Was halt schwierig ist, ein Organ ist ja mehr als nur die Summe seiner Zellen. Und halt diesen ganzen, da gibt es halt so einen Ted Talk, wo halt Leute, die haben halt so eine Niere gedruckt und dann dachten alle, wir können jetzt Organe drucken und das funktioniert. Aber das Problem ist halt, man muss das dann auch irgendwie ankriegen.
Irgendwie muss das Stoffwechsel machen.
Genau, das geht halt noch nicht.
Also das macht wohl halt so einfach Strom dran und den nächsten Blitz abfangen.
Ja, Frankenstein lässt grüßen.
Naja, also die drucken, also zumindest schaffen sie es schon, Zellen zu drucken und die produzieren dann auch noch Harn irgendwie, diese Zellen, diese Nierenzellen. Aber das funktioniert halt noch nicht als Organ. Aber da geht schon einiges. Und so eine Niere kam da in vier Stunden daraus irgendwie. Das ist schon so ziemlich ambulant. Das ist schon eine Qualität irgendwie. Und das wäre halt absolut die Lösung für diesen ganzen Organspende-Skandal und so, frisch gedruckt. Und man muss halt nur sehen, dass man die Pumpe, die immer da rein schiebt, irgendwie jetzt nicht verseucht ist. Und dann geht das. Also da geht auf jeden Fall was.
Da guckt der Heul wie noch.
Ja, ich bin da tatsächlich fasziniert jetzt gerade. Übernehme mal die Sendung Erdgeist.
Ich hab ja irgendwie noch, ich weiß nicht, wie ich jetzt wieder den Segway hinbekommen soll.
Den Segway?
Achso. Segway ist das Englische Wort?
Das ist das Englische Wort.
Sie an. Ich dachte, das wär der Name von diesem albernen Rollern.
Das heißt ja, wie kommt der aus dem Französischen auch? Wo wollte ich hin? Achso, Schlüssel. Schlüssel.
Schlüssel drucken?
Ja, kieke da, wa? Am Ende ist ja so ein Schlüssel auch nichts weiter als irgendwas, was so Pins in so einem Schloss runterdrückt und da muss ja nicht unbedingt Metall sein. Muss ja auch nicht so oft halten. Also wenn du jetzt derjenige bist, stell dir mal vor, irgendwo liegt ein Schlüsselbund rum, du hast eine echt gute Kamera, von weit weg guckst, machst das Foto und fährst dann deinen 3D-Drucker irgendwas an, was da so in das Profil reinpasst. Hast du zumindest für einmal so einen Schlüssel, den du da dann umdrehen kannst. Das heißt, visuell klonen ist jetzt nicht komplett unmöglich. Und wenn du auch schon weißt, was das für ein Schlüssel ist, dann kannst du ja einfach dann die Profilhöhe dir da von dem Bart da abholen und dann musst du da nicht fräsen, sondern druckst einfach. Dann kannst du auch irgendwie außergewöhnliche Profile da einfach dir ausdrucken. Na gut, einfacher ist jetzt auch ein bisschen unseriös benutzt, aber was sagt der?
Also funktioniert, aber wir haben schon Schlüssel gedruckt. Einfacher Schlüssel, aber geht schon.
Und wie oft kannst du die benutzen? Also wie oft schließen die?
Ja, es kommt auf die Größe an so ein bisschen.
Man könnte halt auch Sollbruchschlüssel, also Schlüssel, die tatsächlich nur einmal funktionieren.
Dieses eine geile Projekt von diesen Studenten.
Verdammt, da war ich da. Ich wusste, da wüsste ich gar nichts.
Die haben da DRM-Stühle gebaut. DRM-Stühle?
Ja, die sind klasse.
Die haben dort einen kleinen Mikro-Controller eingebaut in den Stuhl und da so eine Masse, die wenn da Strom angelegt wird, qualmt so ein bisschen in den Fels zusammen. Und dann haben sie einen Stuhl gebaut, wo sie einfach gemessen haben, die hinter den Leuten, die sich draufgesetzt haben. Und nachdem acht verschiedene Leute drauf gesessen haben, ist der Stuhl einfach zusammengeklappt.
Auf dem Zettel steht noch das Wort 3D-Scanner. Wir hatten jetzt eben nur dieses Kinect-Ding, was ja eigentlich nur ein 2D-Scanner ist, oder?
Nö, das ist der Modellieren, ja.
Das heißt, selbst das ist, wo ich jetzt nicht noch jahrelang drauf warten muss.
Es gab auch Leute, die stolz demonstriert haben, wie sie mit so einem Kinectlichen Raum gelaufen sind und dann einfach auch live die T-Kanne, die da stand, als Modell rausextrapoliert haben. Und dann haben sie die T-Kanne weggenommen und danach das Abbild der T-Kanne wieder hingemapt. Das ist schon alles so letztes Jahr.
Da kannst du dir eine Puppenstube aus deinem eigenen Wohnzimmer drucken, aber die Auflösung ist natürlich beschränkt bei einer Kinect. Also eigentlich, wenn man ja mit einem Laser scannt oder irgendwas Feineres haben.
Haben die da jetzt nicht noch irgendwie was rausgebracht, was neu ist, vor ein paar Tagen, so mit der neuen Xbox, so einen neuen, weiss nicht, wie voll...
Wer hätte gedacht, dass irgendwann mal die Spieleindustrie möglicherweise, zumindest diejenigen sein, werden die als Zulieferbetrieb für 3D-Druck in Frage kommen?
Ach, da kommen schon wie geile Dinge raus. V-Mode war ja auch ein total geiles Spielzeug für 30 Euro. Da kannst du ein total cooles Board mit einer geilen Sensorenverlangung benutzen. Vorne eine Kamera drin, die auch noch einen FPGA hat, der dir Punkte ausrechnet, die es so sieht. Beschleunigungs-Sensoren, das ist auch alles total cool. Natürlich sind die Spielehersteller hinterher und wollen geile Interfaces anbieten. Klar kann man die dann für andere spannende Dinge mit benutzen.
Eine Luftröhre haben sie gedruckt. Die haben die Mädchen mit gerettet. Genau, gerade jemand einen Link geschickt auf ADN. Eine Luftröhre ab.net.
Dieser neumodische Scheiß.
Willst du einen Invite? Eine Luftröhre. Ja, ich bin fasziniert.
Man kann auch Lebensmittel drucken. Also Schokolade oder Kuchen drucken oder Kuchen B drucken.
Aber das ist ja nichts anderes als irgendwas aufgelöstes.
Das macht der Auto nicht.
Man macht das anders. Man kann halt so einen 3D-Drucker nehmen und statt des Hotends, wo das Plastik rauskommt, macht man eine Spritze dran. Und dann muss man sich überlegen, so mit Zuckerguss oder irgendwas, was schnell austrocknet. Und dann kann man halt aufschichten. Es gibt Leute, die bedrucken damit einen Kuchen oder so.
Kann man mit 3D-Druckern auch so nicht-euklidische Bälle ausdrucken?
Was sind denn nicht-euklidische Bälle? Ich hab wieder den Witz nicht verstanden. So seid ihr immer zu mir.
Hast du den nicht irgendwann mal gebracht?
Nee, es gab hier so einen Jingle. Ein Witz für die Freunde nicht-euklidischer Geometrie.
Genau, mein Ball ist umgekippt.
Ja, aber den hatte ich nicht wirklich verstanden. Ich hab verstanden, dass da ein Witz drin sein muss. Aber warum das witzig ist...
Ach, dann hast du einfach nur so gelacht.
Alter, was glaubst du, warum ich auf dieser Seite von diesem Pult sitze?
Du hast mich da echt beeindruckt. Ich hab echt geglaubt, du hättest den Witz verstanden.
Ich kann unglaublich gut glaubhaft versichern, dass ich alles verstehe, was man mir sagt. Aber nur so aussehen reicht halt auf Dauer nicht unbedingt.
Naturwissenschaftlich, nein, geisteswissenschaftlich aussehen.
Werden sie uns irgendwann aus 3D-Drucken verbieten? Da sind sie dabei. Sie sind schon dabei?
Na ja, ich meine, mit den Waffen geht's halt los. Da kommt die Diskussion und dann so, Waffen dürfen nicht gedruckt werden oder so. Ich meine, wir haben das gleiche bei Fotokopierern, die drucken halt keine Geldscheine. Also die kopieren halt keine Geldscheine, die liegen so mal drauf, dann kommt ein schwarzes Blatt drauf.
Erzähl mal Geldscheine. Wenn man Schallplatten drucken kann...
Ich hab neulich einen Satz aus Geldscheinen gedruckt.
Aus Geldscheinen aufgeklebt?
Ja, also ich hab 5 Euro Aufkleber. Im Original.
Mit einem 3D-Drucker kannst du halt ein ganzes Bündel drucken.
Wenn man Schallplatten drucken kann, kann man dann nicht auch so Druckplatten für Geldscheine mit drucken?
Ja, das ist dann halt eine Genauigkeitsfrage.
Wie sind die eigentlich? Was ist denn das? Sind die geätzt, gefräst?
Ja, inzwischen wohl geätzt oder so mit Glasmaster und...
Also ich weiß nicht, wie die die Anforderungen sind.
Also ein Geldfälscher Spezialexpert. Also wenn jemand euch zufällig hier gerade zuhört, der von Geldfälschen viel Ahnung hat, in 50 Minuten haben wir noch.
Wird es dann, genau, 033 177 97 110, wird es dann irgendwann, ich weiß gar nicht, ist es hackern möglich, trotzdem Geld zu kopieren an den Kopierer? Oder ist es tatsächlich nicht mehr machbar? Also wird es hackern in der Zukunft möglich sein, trotzdem zu drucken, was sie drucken wollen?
Ja, da ist ja immer noch eine Firmware in so einem Drucker drin. Die Firmware guckt danach, ob sie da dieses eine Muster, die haben irgendwie mehrere Muster inzwischen drin, so einmal diese Eurian-Konstellation mit den Sterben da, diese Fünfecke, die sie da wieder erkennen und haben neuerdings auch noch einen Watermark im Hintergrund drin, wie sie da schon aus 20 Prozent des Bildes daraus extrahieren können. Aber das ist ja auch nur eine Firmware da drin, die einen Blob beinhaltet, der ihnen zugeliefert wird und wenn man den deaktiviert, kann man wieder alles drucken, was man möchte. Da muss man kein Hacker zu sein, sondern einfach nur die Firmware mal.
In meinem Universum ist man dann schon ein Hacker, wenn man die Firmware austauschen kann.
Du wirst mit diesem Wort immer sehr leichtfertig sein.
Mein Universum ist sehr klein. Ihr klingelt ins Telefon, ich würde so gerne rangehen, aber es geht gerade nicht.
Der ehemalige Microsoft-Technikchef hat so ein tolles Patent-Troll-Enterprise gegründet und die heißen intellectual ventures, ist schon so ein toller Troll-Name. Die haben sich das patentieren lassen, also Kopierschutz für Drucker. Dass du praktisch erst so ein Code, das Objekt, so ein Berechtigungscode brauchst, um was auszudrucken. Und nur wenn dieser Code halt stimmt, wenn du das durch den Drucker jagst, dann darfst du was ausdrucken. Das haben sie sich patentieren lassen. Ich weiß nicht, ob da irgendwie noch mehr dahinter steckt oder ob es einfach nur Patent-Trollen ist, keine Ahnung.
Da wird diese ganze Sache, die gerade, ich habe mich gerade erst dazu geschaltet, habe gerade ein bisschen mitgehört, da wird die ganze Sache schon eine ganze Weile verfolgt und auch wirklich angewandt.
Ich dachte, mein Zahn würde, also mein Inlay wäre jetzt so modelliert worden irgendwie.
Die Variante gibt es auch, aber man kann natürlich auch den Zahn bzw. die Preparation einscannen und dann hat man die Möglichkeit, aus den verschiedenen Materialien die ganze Sache fräsen zu lassen.
Gedruckt wird da aber noch nicht.
Ähnlich. Zum Beispiel kann man zum Beispiel eine Krone, die kann man normalerweise, die wurde ja normalerweise modelliert und nachher gegossen. Die wird heute eingescannt mit einer Catcam-Software modelliert am PC und dann wird die ganze Sache entwendet, zum Beispiel mit einem sogenannten Laser-Mating-Verfahren, wird die zusammengesintert. Da muss man sich vorstellen wie ein Drucker, der in verschiedenen Schichten halt druckt. Und da haben wir anstatt Papier, haben wir halt eine Schicht aus Metallpulver und ein Laser geht da oben rüber und sintert das Metall zusammen. Und dadurch entsteht die 3D-Form.
Ich hatte jetzt gedacht, da fallen richtig Zähne raus, die man dann so implantieren kriegen kann.
Die würden sonst aus einem Metallblock gefräst werden. Die Variante gibt es auch natürlich.
Geht auch Keramik oder ist das alles Metall?
Ja, Keramik geht auch. Das nennt man dann Zirkulopfit. Wird halt schon seit vielen Jahren angewandt.
Und die Zahnärzte haben ja auch die ganzen Polymere, so Lichtaushärtenes Material, also so mit UV-Lichtaushärten und so.
Aber ich finde die Sache sehr superspannend. Gut, bestimmte Sachen muss man halt mit Handwerk auch noch ersetzen.
Kannst du denn da irgendwie auch Privatscheiß drucken? Also das sagst du hier scheiße nicht.
So was sehe ich noch nicht.
Kannst du dir dann wie so Austauschzähne machen? Jetzt würde ich halt mal wie Dracula rumlaufen, zum Beispiel draufstecken oder so.
Na ja, wird ja sehr viel gemacht. Leute lassen sich pürzen, ob das gesund ist oder nicht. Ist auch nur die andere Frage. Man sollte es doch dem Fachmann überlassen. Also ich glaube, der Weg zum Zahnarzt, der muss auf alle Fälle sein. Und die Sachen, wir sprechen ja, persönlich wie sie habt ihr das vorhin angesprochen, ich habe gerade vielleicht noch eine Stunde zu. Es gibt ja halt diese 3D-Drucker, die haben natürlich nicht die Präzision. Ich glaube, diese bewegen sich so 0, 3 Millimeter, dieses Kunststoffmaterial. Für Privatvariante ist das okay. Aber wirklich, dass man halt die Präzision hat, die man normalerweise in der Dauertechnik braucht, die haben wir da noch nicht.
Damit man auch hübsch aussieht, kann man nicht geben?
Ich glaube, zum Beispiel ein günstiger Scanner kostet, glaube ich, um die 20.000, 25.000 Euro. Das möchte natürlich jemand privat auch nicht bezahlen. Softwarelizenz bewegen wir uns bei 1.500 Euro.
Dann plus rentiert sich das dann irgendwann für die Szene? Ab irgendeiner Größenordnung? Wie viel Geld spart man denn da so mit, wenn man sich das drucken lässt statt...
Momentan ist der Goldpreis relativ hoch. Und wenn man natürlich in Zukunft wichtige Sachen anzeiten lässt, erspart man sich natürlich den Goldpreis.
Nee, ich mein jetzt immer im Vergleich zum klassischen Modellieren. Geht das schneller oder muss man irgendwie so die Technik...
Wenn gut der Techniker hier dran sitzt, der kann natürlich genauso gut schnell modellieren. Aber wenn wir modellieren, muss es natürlich auch in Gold gegossen werden. Der Arbeitsschritt ist halt länger und da erspart man sich ein paar Sachen, die man dann halt einfach nicht hat.
Okay, aber Gold kann man nicht so 3D drucken?
Ja, also die Variante ist halt einfach so da. Ich finde die Sache einfach halt relativ spannend. Ich bin da auch schon mal nachgeguckt, dieser Web App, der druckt sich ja alleine. Da gibt es ja so einen Community, da sind die relativ offen. Meine Idee, ich bin ja auch Brillenträger, ich finde das ganz interessant, morgen möchte ich mal wieder eine neue Brille haben, mal eine andere Farbe, und dann setze ich mich mal abends an den Drucker ran, an die Software ran und morgen komme ich mir wieder mit einer neuen Brille an.
Da gab es tatsächlich so ein Start-up irgendwo in den USA, die halt dann so Fotos von deinem Gesicht gemacht haben, dann haben die das ausgemessen, und dann konntest du noch ein bisschen an der Brille dran rumdesignen, und dann konntest du die drucken. Ich weiß aber nicht, was draus geworden ist.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das ist nur eine Frage der Zeit. Haben die großen Elektromärkte so ein Ding, anstatt ein normaler Drucker hat dann jeder halt so ein Leder?
Und wenn da noch ein Elektromarkt ist?
Im Drogerieladen steht da neben dem Fotodrucker der Item-Drucker.
Ja, da kannst du ja gleich deine Unterwäsche, deine Kanabenschrögenbekleidung...
Denken wir 20 Jahre zurück, da konnte sich auch keiner vorstellen, dass man halt an ein oder anderen Ort ein Rad sieht und sich sein Foto ausdruckt.
Ja, da kann man sich vieles nicht vorstellen. Das ganze Internet, ne?
Ja, ich freu mich ja schon, wenn dann halt auf dem Mars nachher mein Körper zusammen gedruckt wird. Man nennt es dann halt einfach nur Beam.
Nur Beam?
Einfach nur so.
Wir haben ein Problem mit der Datenmenge, aber es ist halt unverstellbar. Aber wir kommen da irgendwann hin.
Da wüsste ich gar nicht mal, wie realistisch das ist. Ob es da jemanden gibt, der das schon mal gerechnet hat. Also ob das überhaupt...
Doch, ich hab's letztens im Fernsehen gesehen.
Du musstest ja die RRH spielen, wenn es im Fernsehen kommt.
Aber der Rechner bräuchte so lange, solange es jetzt hier ist, das Universum noch gar nicht.
Das kann man bestimmt noch optimieren.
Nicht im Jahr warten.
Wir sind noch eine Weile enttarnt davon.
Martin, all die Fragen, die du dir sonst noch stellst, von wegen der Drucker, der sich selbst drückt, wir haben das heute schon besprochen. Du kannst dir auf fritz.de hinterher die Sendung noch mal runterladen und anhören.
Das weiß ich doch.
Das ist ganz interessant für dich noch. Ich bin informiert. Ach ja, hätte ich auch noch informiert.
Du hast jetzt nur den Prototyp des Zuhörers.
Genau, Protozuhörer. Jo, vielen Dank dir auch. Hier steht noch was ganz Interessantes. Häuser drucken steht auch noch auf dem Zettel. Nicht Häuser, Autos. Entschuldigung, da drunter steht Autos.
Ja, da gab es diese geile Werbung von Was Gema oder so. You wouldn't download a car?
Das heißt, es gibt hier jemand, der ein Auto druckt.
Ja, der ein druckbares Auto entwickelt hat.
Das heißt, es existiert nur als Software, weil es keinen Drucker gibt, der groß genug ist, um so ein Ding zu drucken?
Ich hab auch ein Foto gesehen. Ich hab's nicht genau verfolgt.
Ich glaub, diese Schalenteile haben sie wohl ausgedruckt. Ich weiß aber gar nicht, welches das Verfahren es genau war. Es ging auch so ein bisschen darum, zu zeigen, was mit dieser additiven, also mit 3D-Drucken halt so möglich ist. Und das war auch so ein bisschen Prototyp. Also es ist wohl als eine Elektro-Otto, glaub ich, gewesen.
Der Trabi ist gefahren und das hätte man auch nicht gedacht, ob die Materialien...
Ich hab letztens mal einen angequatscht auf dem Supermarkt, auf dem Parkplatz. Ich komme aus dem Westen. Wie viel verbraucht der eigentlich? Dann sagt der Typ so zwischen 8 und 10 Litern. Zwei-Takt-Gemisch. Das ist mal richtig eklig und teuer. Da bin ich ein bisschen erschüttert. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass der Trabi so viel verbraucht. Aber jetzt sind wir beim Trabi.
Purer Luxus im Sozialismus.
Was drucken wir noch? Komm so zum Abschluss irgendwie. Druck-Anekdoten. Sex-Toys. Sex-Toys. Sex-Toys ist ja naheliegend.
Echt?
Ich fress da irgendwie nicht bei der Pampe da.
Du kannst aus Plastik modellieren, was auch immer du modellieren willst.
Ich hab Lust, dass es wie Würste. Du willst nicht dabei gewesen sein.
Du willst nicht wissen, wie der Dildo entstanden ist.
Es gibt doch den Justin Bieber Dildo. Bei makealove.com.
Was ist Makealove?
Das ist so eine Seite, weil bei Singiverse wollen die Dildos nicht so haben. Ich hatte mal aus Recherchegründen gesucht nach Dildos. Dann gab es keine. Ich glaube, die wollten ihren guten Ruf retten. Dann hieß es ja am Ende, weil ein Dildo ist halt wirklich so einfach zu modellieren. Dann hat wahrscheinlich, ich lad jetzt mal mein Dildo hoch, dachten sich wahrscheinlich viele. Die haben sie halt irgendwie alle gesperrt.
Ach, die haben ihre eigenen... Nee. Die haben versucht, ihre eigenen Schwänze nachzumodellieren.
Naja, wahrscheinlich haben viele Leute mal versucht. Naja, reicht ja schon, wenn du halt einen Zylinder und eine Halbkugel drauf, dann hast du dein Dildo. Und...
Dabei weiß doch jeder, dass es ein Leuchtturm sein soll. Die haben die noch nicht angemalt.
Da gibt es auch.
Es gibt eine Parodie-Seite von Thingiverse, die heißt Dongiverse. Und da suchen sie alle Objekte, die irgendwie wie ein Dildo aussehen und stellen die dann rein. Und ne, makealove.com ist halt richtig... Also da sind halt so diverse Dildos, da kann man sich runterladen als STL-Pfeil und dann kann man die sich drucken, wenn man Lust hat.
Auch bewerten, bestimmt, Community.
Damit wird dann auch die Frage geklärt, wie diese Nacht weitergeht.
Ja.
Wir gehen nach Hause. Das war Chaosradio 190, downloadbar hinterher auf fritz.de oder chaosradio.ccc.de. Im Studio waren der Erdgeist, der Micha und der Pat. Ich bin Holger Klein und das war mein letztes Chaosradio. Hab ich vor sechs Jahren auch schon mal gesagt, ich weiß, aber mal gucken, vielleicht stehe ich dann in sechs Jahren auch schon wieder hier. Danke, Holger.
Kommt jetzt noch Konfetti von der Decke oder so zum Abschied?
Nee, draußen gibt es noch ein paar Crack-Noten, aber nur für mich.
Und ein paar Justin Bieber-Dildas.
Verdammt, so hatten wir nicht gewettet. Ab nächsten Monat gibt es dann auch wieder ein Chaosradio, immer am letzten Donnerstag im Monat, dann wieder mit Markus Richter, den ich die letzten sechs Monate vertreten habe. Schönen Dank, gute Nacht und danke für die Aufmerksamkeit.
Tschüssi.
Ihr dürft jetzt alle mal Tschüss sagen.